an exclusive report just dropped over in
the daily mail joe biden could be
embroiled in the fbi probe into hunter's
finances experts say
emails reveal they shared bank accounts
and they paid each other's bills and wow
that's a huge red flag especially if
hunter biden is doing deals and he's
being flown out on air force to buy his
dad to china for private equity
and they share a bank account
yikes now i don't know the full details
of what's going on between their bank
account maybe they get something worked
out maybe there's an entity that
actually controls the account and then
they just both have access but either
way if they're using the money
interchangeably then yeah the big guy's
getting getting kickbacks on his son's
deals more and more information is
coming out
we're seeing photos of joe biden meeting
with hunter biden's partners the lies
are just unraveling i think most of us
realize it most of us knew the story uh
before we even got to this point and of
course is why twitter was shutting the
story down back during the election
because it was really really bad for joe
and now we're stuck with him but regular
people are
they're fed up i mean we've got 4.3
million resignations out in august we've
got shortages of basically everything
cargo ports railways everything is
jammed up trucker shortages and it's all
under joe biden things are not returning
to normal and it seems like
they like it they're okay with it
so now we are seeing joe biden with the
worst aggregate approval rating of his
nine months
and he's already at 43. when donald
trump was being impeached he actually
had the highest approval rating of his
term so i can't i can't understand how
someone could be so despised at this
point
and not be impeached when trump could be
or i i should say i do get it the media
was just after trump no matter what he
did and biden can do no wrong but here
we are sooner or later people have to
wake up and realize what's happening so
we're gonna go through this we got a
bunch of news we have a major scandal in
loudoun county with these parents who
have been challenging critical race
theory turns out we got to keep this one
family friendly this is a disgusting
story a man whose daughter was abused in
a bathroom by a transgender student
tried to bring the issue up and was
tackled and dragged out the scandal was
covered up and now it is all being
revealed thanks to reporting by the
daily wire so we're going to get all
this stuff joining us today is vocal
distance
i'm going to need you to just introduce
yourself and explain who you are for
everybody my name is local distance
that's my internet moniker you can find
me at local underscore distance on
twitter i'm a visiting fellow at the
center for renewing america and i work
in the area of post-modernism and
critical theory so so you have these
threads all over twitter just breaking
down critical race theory critical
theory gender theory all that stuff
basically wokeness yes that's right i
want to
find
dig up and explain the intellectual and
academic roots of what we call wokeness
and the woke movement so that people can
understand exactly what they're dealing
with when woke people
say things to them which to the rest of
us might not
seem to make a lot of sense but how
within their own internal system it can
be coherent some people uh
one easy way to explain it is you've
done work with james lindsey yes yeah
james lindsey is a is a good friend of
mine um we read a
retreat some time ago the pictures are
out there with some other people and
james is an excellent source he's
helped his book cynical theories was was
very instructive
and him and i go back for a few years
now and we've been working on this
problem right now he's excellent we got
a lot to talk about we also got luke
witkowski we got way too much to talk
about holy cow was today a quote good
day we're finding out that the president
might might have inadvertently funded
his son's 2018 drug and prostitution
binge we're finding out texas is banning
all vaccine mandates by any entity judge
in new york is refusing uh the the
exemption the religious exemption to
health care workers he's actually
approving it there's the freedom flu
going around netflix refuses to remove
dave chappelle holy cow i mean it's just
an absolutely crazy day and we got a lot
to talk about we've been working on the
studio so we've got a bunch of stuff
that uh that we're putting up that we're
fixing and then i come up here and i'm
like okay so what's what's the news for
today obviously we have the joe biden's
approval rating and then there's the
story joe biden shared a bank account
with his son and i'm like wow that
basically means it was his kickback it's
like that's it i don't know where you go
from there when the president himself is
getting money in these kickbacks and
they're just flat out saying it so yeah
they're big news huh there's a lot of
implications here but yeah i'm here i'm
liquoredowski if we are change.org and i
have a youtube channel that is we are
change so there's having me a vast
reservoir of knowledge about to be
released into this room so i'm gonna
relax sit back and enjoy the ride yes mr
crossland here what's up can i can i
just add one thing to your to your joe
biden bit
if money was deposited
that went into joe biden's bank account
or or a bank account that joe biden had
access to the question immediately
becomes if we'll
from watergate what did the president
know
and when did he know it yeah i mean he
clearly knows when money goes into his
account oh no i didn't know i was just
using the bank out paying my bills with
it while my son was actively taking
money from foreign governments and then
i went to ukraine and got a prosecutor
fired who was investigating the sunlight
the company my son was was abort was a
director at uh yeah i think we know
where this is going we'll get into this
stuff we'll get into it we'll we'll save
something we got lydia pressing the
buttons i'm also here i'm attempting to
more successfully push buttons tonight
uh there are a lot more buttons to push
than i had before so wish me luck
tonight soon to be way more but before
we get started my friends go to
timcast.com become a member and you'll
get access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim castillo podcast you
especially want to go check the website
right now and the members only section
for the tim castro podcast because there
is big news but we're going to wait
until the end of the show to announce
what's going on so sign up become a
member support our work we're gonna have
a member segment coming up around 11 or
so p.m you don't want to miss it and uh
just you know don't forget to like share
subscribe all of that stuff apparently
that helps us a whole lot on youtube
sharing is the best thing you do take
that url share it wherever you can leave
us a good review let's get into this
news this is big big stuff we got the
story from the daily mail exclusive
joe biden could become embroiled in the
fbi's probe into hunter's finances
experts say i love that experts say
emails reveal they shared bank accounts
paid each other's bills and the
president may have even funded his son's
2018 drug and prostitution binge
we're going to be a little careful on
this one because we try to be a
family-friendly show but uh when it
comes to the president and his son it's
anything but family-friendly from joe
biden touching children and sniffing
them inappropriately to his son doing
crack i'm sorry we can only cover up so
much in an attempt to protect your
children's ears the daily mail says
president joe biden could become
embroiled in an fbi investigation let me
just stop and say yeah right as if
they're going to do anything
emails recovered by dailymail.com from
hunter's abandoned laptop his uh between
his business uh him and uh between
hunter and eric schwerin his business
partner at roosevelt seneca show
schwerin was working on joe's taxes
discussing the father and son paying
each other's household bills and even
fielding requests for a book deal for
them by the vice for the then vice
president yes it is unclear why schwerin
had the intimate role in the vice
president's affairs rather than
government officials in the oval in the
office of the vice president hunter's
claim that he and his father shared a
bank account also raises serious
questions whether funds from the alleged
joint account were used for hunter's may
2018 week-long bender well look if you
have a bank account it's got a dollar in
it and then someone puts a dollar in it
the money is mixed up now and then if
you take a dollar out yeah sorry we
don't play that game this is how like
you know when when the feds go after
money laundering you can't just be like
it's one bank account but all of our
money is different they're gonna be like
nah you're mixing it all together
they say last december hunter admitted
in a public statement that he was under
federal investigation over his tax
affairs all right let's let's slow down
for a second so now we're learning
joe biden
sharing a bank out with his son
hunter biden on the board of barisma
getting paid was eighty three thousand
dollars per month yeah
bursma being investigated or i should
say mykolo zlachevsky the founder of it
being investigated by the prosecutor
victor shoken joe biden goes to ukraine
and says if you don't fire the
prosecutor you don't get there was it a
billion dollars yeah
it was huge and so they say okay fine
they fire the prosecutor official
narrative from the u.s establishment
mainstream medias oh they fired him
because he wasn't investigating this guy
so
hunter biden who has no business being
on the board of this company a company
that's under investigation getting paid
83 grand sharing a bank account with his
dad his dad then goes in
fires a prosecutor who is investigating
the company we know this from matt
taibi's reporting
sounds like joe biden was protecting his
own assets by going to ukraine
getting this guy fired it wasn't about
corruption it was it wasn't about
anything other than his own corruption
so what what do we do with information
like that
i'm
unfortunately you already have the tv
show so let's talk about it we can all
shake our fists in the air and then
tomorrow wake up because nothing changes
no this dude's a scumbag and i think
this is going to be big news you can
they hid they tried to hide the laptop
scandal with the post story yeah you
brought up a very important point here
ian the the fact that there was so much
censorship especially around the hunter
biden email stories because this i mean
the daily mail says that they got the
story from the emails so the fact that
there was so much suppression shows that
they actually do care about what the
public thinks about them they actually
do need the public to acquiesce and
there's a large number of voters that
said that if they knew about these
emails they would they would have voted
differently so so this of course has a
lot of implications i mean we know he
lied about the uh on the on the atf form
when it comes to buying firearms he lied
about a lot of other things as well that
he should have been you know kept you
know be held responsible for liable for
i mean the guy is on video committing
acts there's photos of him committing
acts that we can't even mention here on
youtube let me let me let me read this
portion of the story because y'all's
jaws are gonna hit the floor no hunter
and schwerin privately discussed the
potential to ingratiate themselves with
quote ceos of the major banks if they
helped arrange the request this is to
senator robert menendez uh who requested
vp biden host the u.s spain's council
2010 annual meeting at his official
naval observatory residence in dc they
contacted schwerin rather than joe's
white house office interestingly we then
see this
hunter complained that half of his
salary went to paying his father's bills
while he was vp casting doubt on joe's
previous claim that he's never benefited
from his son's business dealings in a
2019 text to his daughter naomi he wrote
i hope you all can do what i did and pay
for everything for this entire family
for 30 years it's really hard but don't
worry unlike pop i won't make you give
me half your salary so that's previously
uncovered information
now we have joe biden sharing a bank
account with his son this is let me
explain something to you
i have i have an accountant
and i'm like hey what can i do to help
you know help help my family out and and
he goes nothing oh nothing
you cannot do anything special for
family for the most part for the most
part there's certain things like friends
and family you know with investment
stuff but if you want to give someone
money it's taxed
it's either a gift up to a certain limit
right now i believe the limit is 15 000
and after that you got to pay taxes on
it if they're splitting bank accounts
and they're as wealthy as you know we
know they're wealthy then
this is what is this tax avoidance how
much money went into this bank account i
don't know for sure we don't we i i
don't know for sure and i think the
issue is
as soon as they mix their finances
questions have to be raised about any
and all of their finances all of them
yeah i was going to say i heard a really
familiar voice a really familiar name in
the story and that was bob menendez do
you guys remember bob menendez and what
he got in trouble for
something about the dominican republic
and some kind of young women young
ladies yes we'll put it that way so as
far as i'm concerned i don't see
anything bad ever happening to the
bidens based on what happened to bob
menendez aka nothing i don't think
anything's gonna happen how do you look
it's kind of it's kind of funny when you
know under trump they were like trump
won't be investigated because bill barr
is as lacky and it's never going to
happen and i'm sitting here like in
merrick garland what's he going to do
you think mark garland's going to go
after joe biden and be like lock him up
he's going to be like hey joe they're
talking about you can i have some money
there you go yep
i think it's also hilarious that this is
the same president lecturing parents
about how they should raise their
children
i mean i mean are you kidding me
yeah no no it's fair let's be serious
here i mean
if if you're hunter biden's father you
can't be telling other people how to
raise your children you can't be telling
people to you know giving them specific
because
he came out and said you know if you're
if you're not following the science if
you're not taking these procedures
you're not raising your children right
and
again there's a lot to say about that
but there's just so much corruption so
much dirtiness i mean we have the
flights to china we have the business
dealings with ukraine we have so many
companies just intertwined and and
yesterday on the show i specifically
said sorry i'm having like headphones
problems and i keep hearing myself back
so i keep getting distracted
i'm sorry
it's just weird hearing your own voice
but but there's so many instances and as
i said yesterday
you know this country has been sold for
pennies on the dollar and the way you
buy influence the way that you buy off
politicians the way that our system
works is incredibly easy for a third
party to come in and to manipulate this
for their own benefit in so many
different ways having dirt having videos
of biden doing unspeakable things with
women with relatives with family members
i mean that's top-notch top-level
extortion level
material that could be leveraged that we
knew that we know many foreign countries
had before now this is what we know what
don't we know about what wasn't in the
emails that we still don't know about
that many that maybe foreign countries
have that could be using to exploit the
current president of the united states
you know how i feel about this story i
feel like you know we get this bombshell
revelation oh joe biden sharing banks
like they're funding each other and joe
biden potentially paying for hookers and
stuff i feel like i just
burst into the room and i'm like
everybody listen
joe biden's are corrupt and everyone's
like oh [ __ ] we know
so what is this what are you even
talking about and i'm like but we have
the story and they're like yeah whatever
what do you do
are we gonna see a a a red wave in 2022
maybe an impeachment the dude needs to
be impeached please
yeah then we're going to have you know
president kamala and her child actors
that she hires yeah
laughing to the camera as she like does
weird strange bizarre videos promoting
space and looking at the craters of the
moon for some reason it's it's
reassuring you know you know with all
the economic calamities with so much
problems that that the white house is
spending money on child actors to convey
people about looking at the moon i mean
are you freaking kidding me they're so
out of touch with reality they hope no
one's paying attention they want you to
feel like hey there's so much corruption
it's just okay it's the new norm it's
not it's not okay and i think there's a
reason what ian brought up here that
censorship happened of these emails the
censorship was crucial i think it would
have made a big impact in the elections
and i think it's going to make an impact
later down the line in this political
spectrum when people look at the
president look at the clear corruption
look at the clear dereliction of duty
look at the cleared mess left by him and
being like how could have we not seen
this happening well because of big tech
social online censorship
i'd like to make two points
i would like to make two points about
that
guys in the chat are going that's about
my not being loud enough so speaking out
a little bit here we go all right
i would like to point out i would like
to say that jean baudrillard is going to
be spinning in his grave over that stunt
that kamala pulled absolutely
unbelievable because every ounce of that
is fake
the whole thing is a pre-fabricated
commercial
where you're supposed to bring people in
so that they can kamala has a chance to
go out and impress them so to set up to
begin with
but it's not even a real setup
it's a it's supposed to be a setup of a
spontaneous moment but it's not even a
real setup of a spontaneous moment it's
a fake
setup of a spontaneous moment it's two
levels of fate it's a fake of a fake
it's a copy of a copy so they have
actors who are paid to act like they're
real people so that kamala can come in
and act like a spontaneous moment that's
not set up and prefabricated ahead of
time that they auditioned for yes so you
had to audition
for a spontaneous moment
what a creepy fake reality who's the
last genuine president i guess trump was
not no he wasn't he wasn't genuine
either the way he said uh now i'm
getting that weird tinny sound of my
headphones the way he said uh gee lane
he hopes wishes are well i i don't know
i think trump was very straightforward
and he just bluntly said that and many
other things maybe trump before that
jimmy carter because reagan was full of
it i try to watch old interviews with
reagan and he's just like smiling and
like oh they're going to use the next
it's all theater it's all a show that's
why they're literally building a stage
for joe biden to not be in the white
house in that's that's as it's it's
played on like like a theater yeah
everything we're seeing is just horse
and pony it's all a showcase it's meant
to fool you into this larger kind of
illusion that they actually have power
over you when they when they desperately
need to have that conviction well we
have more news ladies and gentlemen
joe biden's aggregate approval rating is
just getting massively worse breaking a
new record high disapproval and a new
record low approval wow this is just
it's getting bad disapproval is at 52.3
his approval is down to 43 and look at
this major spike
regular people are starting to wake up
to what's going on joe biden is bad he
is corrupt his leadership is failing
this country we got a southern border
crisis an economic crisis a jobs crisis
a mass resignation crisis an inflation
crisis stagflation shrink flation just
any kind of inflation just maybe you got
it yeah you got all of them
enough to go around for everybody it
looks like that inflection points were
right about when he
came out with this mandate nonsense it's
true yeah right around the time he
announced the man when the mandate
started becoming big there was a major
swap and by the way those aren't actual
mandates osha has not approved these
things yet right
it was his announcement of a rule to be
and osha has not implemented any rules
and there's no executive order yet we're
seeing all these businesses just go
along with it
this is what i think
a lot of people
anti-elected trump
as we mentioned over and over again on
the show that there was at articles just
stay alive joe biden right and this is
what you get when you don't have a
legitimate
like administration and what i mean by
that is an administration that is
actually going to do the job that is
actually having the meetings joe biden
is probably asleep with a with a burlap
blanket on his on his laps in the sun
snoring all day while kamala is just
like what do i got to do to make it seem
like i'm working give me some child
actress or something and i'll just
pretend and then i'm done right that's
that's where we're at you are here yep
so biden was unelected and we're seeing
the result of choosing people based on
like color of their skin and their
gender and sexual orientation we're
seeing pete buddha judge being totally
incompetent kamala harris just cackling
her way through being a terrible vice
president it's tackling her way through
the vice president it's so bad but this
is what happens when you hire people
based on you know checking a demographic
box they're totally incompetent and
everyone's shocked by this it's also
kind of what happens when you
treat the political realm like a reality
tv show they just put they want monkey
dance monkey dance and then they get
entertainers and stupid people in chart
doing the dance and the people that are
willing to do the dance do the dance and
the people everyone else build
spaceships
so who's building a spaceship is that i
just wanted to see what's mr musk can i
take a chance to just drive something
home yes
we are living in a post-modern era i
keep screaming about this on twitter and
this is how i kind of built my following
we are now living in post-modernism that
why does it make sense that is why well
it's not coherent doesn't need to make
sense this is post-modernism um
i always say that trump is our first
post-modern president he was the first
president of the fully post-modern age
the age of narrative where truth doesn't
matter so you can see that in the entire
media circus around trump or even the
fact checks aren't real right right
you're they're not the fact checks are
not to check if the facts are real
they're to check if they're the
appropriate facts that they approve of
are these approved facts are these the
facts that are helpful to us right
so that's what goes on there and then
as we as we've moved through the biden
presidency
everything about it is fake they built a
fake room so that he could pretend to be
in the white house right
we had we had kamala bring child actors
on so she could pretend to be surprised
and have an authentic moment right and
to be genuine allegedly yeah so we had a
fake genuine moment yeah that's great
yeah
we're having we're going to stage a
genuine moment for the people yeah so
that the people can have a genuine
moment to look at while they're watching
president biden get vaccined in the
white house
in the fake room in the white house this
is this is all simulation it's it's
completely
it's it's an era of complete and utter
inauthenticity
so you've got
there is nothing about it which touches
reality at any point it's entirely
staged it doesn't refer to anything
nothing about it is
rooted in the real world experience of
anybody that's why you have actors who
audition for it it's not just they
brought actors in and said have a good
time or brought actors in and said here
are your lines they brought actors in
and said you have to audition
for the genuineness and surprise
how do you audition for a surprise
how do you audition to be surprised what
does that even mean well actors probably
do it all the time in movies or whatever
yeah i i think a better word than
simulation is simulacrum yes the the the
the uh simulation implies there's a
functioning you know system and we're
trying like is it real something no it's
a caricature and and i i i want to make
sure i got the definition right in
insubstantial replication
it is very obvious
you know uh it's like
it's like a caricature
we're looking at a caricature of an
administration mm-hmm yeah i would agree
with that
i think james o'keefe really
characterized this well where he
compared what's happening now to 1984
when they're asking you to reject the
evidence of your eyes and ears so i
think we're at that particular phase
right now where literally we have
evidence we have photos we have
documentation we have witnesses we have
whistleblowers coming forward screaming
saying hey there's some awful things
happening in this world there are some
really bad people doing horrible things
and then the mainstream media is like
it's weather there's bad weather and and
regurgitating all this nonsense and lies
that is absolutely nonsensical and
anyone paying attention to to anything
that's happening it's just an insult to
their intelligence i got a feeling that
because it seems like since the internet
i started noticing them lying and
creating a mass narrative that's not
real but before the internet i never
realized it but i think they were just
doing it then anyway they're just using
abc news to push it and now at least
it's obvious that there's no weapons of
mass destruction in iraq and it's not
just child actors that they're hiring
they're they're they're hiring social
media uh
influencers they're they're hiring
doctors they're hiding uh they're hiring
other doctor the other actors
they're hiring everyone to kind of prop
them up as this kind of legitimate force
and then when we really look at it a lot
of it is phony a lot of it is based on
lies a lot of it is based on here we'll
give you this money just say these lines
and sadly some people do that do you
guys know the story uh we've talked
about a lot kindergarten's clown you
know he comes out and he's like there's
a fire in the back and then everyone
starts laughing and he's like no
seriously there's a fire and they laugh
even harder and he says i think that's
how the world will end you know whatever
it kind of feels like it's the other way
around you know there's there's a small
group of us and we're sitting in the
audience and on tv is all of these
people
that are all pretending like there's no
fire and we're the ones yelling back
like there is a fire and they're like no
and they just they're just they're
putting on a show they're they're
performing it kind of feels like we we
now exist with a government
of people who are basically like
uh what time is it um what do i have to
do to pretend to do the job so i can get
paid and go home
kamala harris comes out with some child
actors biden builds a fake set you know
what you know what you why i don't
understand the fake set but i can say
biden likes to go home a lot sure does
no but none of these people want to be
working
well hire people who didn't who weren't
right for the job this is what you get
to be fair i sympathize with i
understand people don't want to be at
work most the time i can't really relate
because i love my job but i will say
that this very much to me looks like a
case of bread and circuses and when
you're seeing it in your politics i
think that's
unsettling that's a serious issue
so can i can i throw something out yeah
i'd like to toss something out i think
i think what we're seeing is what i like
to call the strawberry slurpee of a
presidency
okay so here's here's what i mean
suppose we go back in time and we find
some original
natural organic strawberries we pick
them we eat them they taste pretty good
fast forward to the 1960s and all of a
sudden we can we can farm strawberries
and we only take the biggest reddest
juiciest strawberries for consumption
we'll call that a productive coffee well
then someone comes along and says hey
we're in those big juicy strawberries
well we can make a strawberry candy out
of it
okay well then we go a little further
and someone else says yeah we can make a
strawberry candy but we're gonna add
some sugar
okay then someone else comes along and
says yeah we'll make a strawberry candy
but we'll use corn syrup instead of
sugar then someone else says we'll make
a soft drink of the candy and then
somebody else comes along and says we
are going to make a strawberry slurry
slurpee that is flavored like the soda
that is flavored like the candy that is
flavored like the straw and all of a
sudden you're you're so far away from
the original thing that they're not even
comparable the flavor of the strawberry
slurpee is nothing like the flavor of
the organic of the organic thing what we
have right now for a presidency
is nothing like what it's supposed to be
it's entirely entirely what they think
people expect a presidency to look like
that's why they have to build a set so
they can get the perfect angle so that
they can create the image of what they
think people expect a presidency to be
at the cost of what an actual presidency
might actually be if one was really
occurring i i do got some some bad news
to add to that i think raspberry might
be a better example because you guys
know where they get the flavoring for a
raspberry artificial flavor beavers yeah
you think you're eating this delicious
it's it's strawberry they say you're
eating a strawberry you take a bite and
you're like hmm
yeah it's kind of like strawberry
storium and they're like
real it's actually it's actually just
from beaver butt that's right that's
biden's presidency yeah you're eating
some artificial gmo monsanto gene
spliced strawberry shake that doesn't
taste anything like it was supposed to
and it can't but
this is normal since this is what they
gave you since you're a small child even
worse about that is the the the flavor
is not the point it's what you the
nutrition you get from a strawberry
so now we got
we've got
mutilated dis flavor
you're not even getting any of the
nutrition that you need from the valid
strawberry presidency it's not just
biting it's everything
yeah the whole government it's the whole
government it's congress it's the senate
i think they built that room for like
implementing a special teleprompter
that's really big that they can't fit in
the white house yeah just some kind of
new medical advice that like wakes him
up and zaps him
there has to be some there has to be
some reason sometimes
he's got a gigantic series of cables in
his back that go down into a massive
power system it's a giant reactor to
keep him alive he's robo biden that
would make more you remember when i
would make more sense franklin and rose
franklin delano roosevelt started uh he
got paralyzed i think was it polio that
took his legs his walk wasn't he always
no not in the beginning of his
presidency and they hit it for like i
don't know how long two years or
something they hit it yeah so what i
imagine with biden i mean the guy is
decrepit if that's the right word he's
like almost falling
over that's the right word yeah
like if you listened to 10 years ago are
they hiding it
they've done it before definitely
yeah i i don't know but i i want to go
back to your point about the nutrition
thing because i think it's it's just a
perfect point
all of the stuff that should be going on
in congress
isn't
none of it's going on but if you go to
congress it sure looks like there's
stuff going you've got people in suits
walking around very important people
people are exchanging business cards
there's capitol hill police there's a
lot of people that are walking around
looking very very busy they're holding
votes on things nothing's going on it's
entirely fake
this is baudrillard's point and this is
why i say we're living in a post-modern
moment we are living in a time of the
image is what matters the substance is
almost utterly irrelevant if it's even
seen at all we know
they're all
lying is what really really makes me
just so sick of all of this let me let
me pull up this story we had another
story check this out you guys are going
to love it
southwest ceo says he never wanted a
covet vaccine mandate but biden forced
his hand
is that what biden is he's the patsy for
for the ceos for the establishment
they're like i'm imagining the ceo
sitting there and he's like he's trying
to do this vaccine mandate and like the
ceo from some other company like you
know aa's there and it's like
everybody's mad at me what do i do oh
just blame biden what do you mean
you don't blame but you're not blaming
biden for your problems oh biden's our
fall guy yeah all the problems in the
economy right now everything bad
happening you used to say biden did it
okay and he comes out and he's like i
didn't want to vaccinate it biden made
me do it even though biden didn't make
anyone do it because there's no actual
executive order or osha rule but it's a
convenient out for a guy who's who's
collapsing in his approval rating for
the southwest ceo to be like i don't
know everybody seems to be mad at the
guy i'll let him take the fall for me i
think this is a continuation of the same
thing this is them wanting the
appearance of the thing without the
actual thing they want the appearance of
bowing to the superior you know having
some kind of responsibility to what
biden has told them to do even though
they haven't actually made a law or a
rule or even a mandate so they're just
taking the appearance they don't really
care about what's actually true look at
this let me read this they say uh quote
i've never been in favor of corporations
imposing that kind of mandate i'm not in
favor of that never have been but the
executive order from president biden
mandates all federal employees and then
all federal contractors which covers all
major airlines have to have a vaccine
mandate in place by december 8th so
we're working through that now that
sounds a bit circuitous there is the
federal employee mandate as my
understanding but this covers all the
airlines that's i didn't know that
southwest said last week that that's 56
000 employees need to be vaccinated by
by december 8th in order to keep working
for the airline under federal mandate
southwest announcement came a few days
after other carriers american airlines
alaskan airlines and jetblue informed
employees of the need to adhere to
federal vaccine rules in august before
the bond administration's action united
air airlines and hawaiian airlines
instituted coveted vaccine requirements
for their staffs united said earlier
this month that more than 96 percent of
its 67 000 us employees have shared
proof of vaccination after its late
september deadline what was the amount
of employees they had before this was
announced and also just to throw back to
what ian said
around august is when joe biden
announced the vaccine mandates and
that's when his approval rating flipped
the inflection point when all of a
sudden people were like i don't like
this guy because i'll tell you i
mentioned this on the show several times
i know somebody who is like
biden and waving biden flags and now
he's freaking out because he's like my
job is going to force me to do this and
i don't want to
yeah some people are saying that the
southwest ceo is in the world economic
forum is a part of that group and he's
it's also just very convenient to that
that he's just lumping everything on
biden he doesn't have to comply there's
a lot of other people there's a lot of
unions there's a lot of big companies
saying we're not going to comply with
this and there was even a statement
saying that southwest will not be using
the texas exemption as a way to
implement uh you know this vaccine
passport these vaccine
this vaccine mandate which they're
imposing there's also a very interesting
date that they're
setting not just with southwest but many
other corporations are setting the date
of december 8th as the deadline it's all
kind of done in in unison which is oddly
strange as as well but again no one is
forcing southwest to do this it's an
executive order executive decrees are
argued they go to court there's a lot of
very important court battles so he's
moving forward with this and clearly a
lot of his employees a lot of the people
who work for him aren't happy with this
and they're protesting in their own kind
of unique way that we're seeing with
this freedom that's going around i don't
think it's protest
i i think kind of i think yes there's
there's there's a very kind of blurred
line here because the pilots don't want
to get officially in trouble
i don't i don't i don't i don't i talk
to a pilot and he's like
it's worse than a sick out like this i a
lot of people want to believe that all
these pilots are like hey guys should we
jump ship right now and they'll high
five but don't let anyone know because
we'll get in trouble when in reality it
seems like yo
as we've been saying time and time again
you can only push people so far
i don't see evidence of an organized
effort i see regular people just saying
i'm out
and that's that's something
substantially worse
it's like so this is what i was saying
the other day imagine if biden came out
and said in order for everybody to keep
their jobs they got to go punch a baby
and then all of a sudden it's like
record resignations airlines shut down
what's happening it's like dude no one
organized an event not to punch babies
they just won't do it that's what people
need to understand about vaccine
mandates it's not like some guy called
his friend and said let's organize
together and refuse this it's a guy
being like yo i ain't doing that just on
there on his own he didn't need anybody
to tell him to do it
yeah that's fake um that along with
other uh disruptions in our supply
chains on our in our labor uh you know
workforce is something that's only going
to start from now on since of these
deadlines are just encroaching in just a
few days from now so
there's a big conflict happening and
whether it's organized or not organized
it's happening and there's a formidable
force of individuals of people saying
enough is enough i believe in my
personal autonomy i believe in my
personal liberty i believe in being able
to make the right decisions for myself
as a human being and the media is acting
like these people don't even exist they
do exist there's a lot of them there's a
lot more of them than we would even even
know about because they don't want you
knowing about this they don't want you
even talking about the major
demonstrations and protests that have
been happening all over the world in new
york in new york in italy in france in
australia in the united kingdom there's
been major huge rallies with thousands
of people hitting the streets saying hey
this is an unpopular
uh
policy i don't want to ask permission to
go to the supermarket from the
government i don't want big fat
bureaucratic agents who work at the dmv
relegating every aspect of my existence
and what i could do and where i could go
i got i want to point something out too
the southwest ceo is really coming out
against the mandates
sounds like he knows what's really
driving the work strength right
could i can i just ask you you said that
there actually isn't a mandate in place
that he so see the southwest ceo there's
not a real law there's so so biden said
if you've got at least 100 employees you
got to mandate vaccines osha has yet to
implement any rule and there's no
executive order however what the
southwest ceo is saying is that joe
biden did issue an executive order on
federal contractors which includes
airlines therefore
they must adhere to a federal vaccine
mandate now he's in trouble though it's
it's funny that the media comes out and
it's like immediately trying to debunk
the narrative no no pilots aren't aren't
sticking out or anything like that and
i'm like okay technically the truth but
they're just not showing up because they
won't do this now the ceo comes out and
says uh i'm i'm not in favor of vaccine
mandates well hold on there a minute who
cares i thought vaccine minutes had
nothing to do with why there was a major
flight cancellation and and why you were
short-staffed yeah i thought it was
weather
he said it was the weather you know
what's funny is american airlines the
only airline impacted by weather it's
amazing they must fly paper airplanes
that get soggy and fall out of the sky
it's it's complete bs they're lying for
him to come out and be like uh i didn't
want the vaccine mandate sounds like
he's now trying to placate the people
who aren't showing up
yeah and he's trying to shift blame on
himself his personal decisions and blame
it on biden which i think many
multinational corporations have been
doing many powerful interests have been
doing when they implement a lot of their
policies that they would never dare
publicly even speak about but when you
have a guy who's not really even there
who can't even speak properly that's the
perfect opportunity to ram through your
bull crap blame everything on him we
talked about this a few days ago brought
up this point i mean this is absolutely
perfect a genius strategy in order to
get away with these atrocities that
clearly people do not want people are
sick of it there's also two images going
around the internet right now that are
going pretty viral one is a southwest
airplane with the gaston flag outside of
its window and another one is someone in
the southwest uniform putting his head
down with a sign saying no jab no job
why question mark father of five 20-year
navy vet
4 000 hours south west airlines and a
heart that's broken so those two images
are going viral right now and whether
this was you know organized or not i
don't think it even matters at this
point because i think it's clear with
the mandates encroaching especially on
december 8th for many people all over
the world uh for many people in the
united states for many corporations that
these kind of um you know actions that
these kind of disruptions are only going
to get more intense there's some people
calling for a national strike there's
already shortages at amtrak amtrak is
already cancelling a number of train
options for people uh because of you
know issues with their staff
you know again being extremely vague
here let's just call a spade a spade
here a lot of people aren't happy and
they're not staying and they're not
sitting down for it look why december
8th
um i have no idea i think i
i mean we could speculate right now
there's no smoking gun evidence directly
saying why but it could be because it's
right before the holiday season it's
right during crunch time it's right when
everyone
is going to hope to have money to give
their loved ones gifts so that's some of
the speculation out there that
you're saying they want the system to
crash i believe there is an element that
will profit off of the system crashing
and they're making protocols and
restrictions and mandates that will
create a situation that will put us
there i do believe that uh is somewhat
done deliberately by the you know
special interests and powers that do set
to gain from hurting everyone else
can't stand tradition man people feel
locked into this thanksgiving christmas
thing when you could be celebrating with
your family anytime do it now before the
before the junkyard people feel locked
in people in cities don't they have
friends giving just like they hang out i
love that yeah but then there are
families that have thanksgiving
businesses like give people time off on
these certain days every year so it's
like you kind of have to live your life
around those days if you're in that
environment and that can become very
dangerous centralizing your time is very
dangerous well i'm not i'm not a fan of
the holidays because people stop working
yeah and then you know and look the way
the economy works is if other people
stop working i can't work either yeah
because there's only so much so so on
you know on holidays we basically are
just taking time off now and i never i
didn't i didn't used to do this but it
really is working on the holidays like
trying to lift 10 times the weight you
normally lift yeah
boeing also announced that all employees
quote must be vaccinated by december 8th
as well many other corporations are
doing this as well but this is all
because they're allegedly biden's
federal contractors uh and and this is
how again they're making it so just
weird with their uh mandates with their
quote alleged executive orders that that
it's very hard to follow a lot of this
it's not very simple i think it's meant
to confuse a lot of people it's meant to
scare people i think there's a big
agenda to make people fear uh to feel
alone to make them feel scared to make
them feel like resistance is futile when
in many instances it's not all right
well well my friends my friends listen
heed my words we're gonna build back
better baby because we got breaking news
this is amazing 4.3 million americans
quit their jobs in august a new record
great resignation trend continues as job
market upended by pandemic wow this is
amazing news let's get around of let's
go brandon everybody let's go
yeah this is great thank you thank you
uh joe biden let's go brandon for the
mass resignations during a supply
shortage cargo ships being jammed up
trucker shortages labor food gas prices
skyrocketing now 4.3 million people in
august quit their jobs i wonder what the
numbers for september are that's when
the mandate was issued and it's also
important to understand that
again a lot of people here are are
putting themselves in a situation
knowing that they're going to lose
everything and they're saying i might as
well just get out of this crazy
situation if they're going to be
enforcing this and move on and find
another way find another job so i
wouldn't be surprised if most of those
resignations most of those people
quitting were from big companies who
were mandating this and them saying no
i'm not going to go along with this and
i need an out now check this out they
say approximately 4 million people per
month have been leaving their jobs since
the spring as part of a trend that has
become known as the great resignation
uh under joe biden's presidency for some
reason everybody is
everybody's quitting their jobs
great that's a that's amazing that's
good it's a it's a good thing it's
almost like there is yeah it's it's a
good thing um yeah the economy is being
reset at a great level that's what it
sounds like to me i was just gonna say
having this many people resign in the
course of a month that sounds like a
really big reset resignation for the
reset nation exactly yes it does it's
terrifying i wonder what's going to
happen because
people who are
familiar with how supply chains work
know how bottlenecks work right if you
get if you get something that's
constricting and slowing down so right
now there's a lot of backlogged ports
suppose
five percent of truckers
resign because they don't want to get
vaccinated and suppose five percent of
ship
uh captains resign and suppose five
percent of say
warehouse
uh workers resign that's a lot more
friction on an already stressed system
that bottleneck is going to back up in a
real hurry and the question is going to
be what's it going to take to be able to
get out these vaccine mandates if if
they are the cause of this of these
resignations this is going to hit supply
chain stuff and that supply chain stuff
is going to get way worse before it gets
better and the question becomes at a
certain point how do you even unload
those ports
what are you going to do
well walmart home depot these stores are
all chartering private boats now
this is it's really really amazing i
mean look we had 20 20 was bad
right and we can say donald trump did a
good job in 2019 is a great economy 2020
covet hits and then things aren't so
good but we're supposed to be recovering
joe budden has turned what is supposed
to be a rapid resurgence as we reopen
into a complete complete catastrophe
yeah and and to be fair we love to just
throw it at joe biden because he's the
president but it's his administration
every single one of them involved if he
promises something he should be held
accountable for it he also promised the
coveted numbers to go down they've been
going up dramatically with more
intervention more governments getting
involved and again even when it comes to
the ports there's so many things to
unwind there because in the mainstream
media like we saw in this article by the
independent this is all pandemic related
you know job loss economic suffering
inequalities this is all pandemic this
is all because of the sickness no it's
not it's because of the government it's
because of big fat cat bureaucrats
intervening making the situation that
much worse and not really helping anyone
out especially when you look at the
scientific data and you see direct
intervention mandates restrictions
lockdowns and you see places that didn't
follow it you look at the cases you look
at the numbers the hospitalizations the
debts there's not a big difference there
at all and some would argue that the
situation has been exacerbated to its
fullest extent with the ports there's
there's literal ships that are ready to
dock they can't because one of their
workers tested sick what what do many of
these boats have to do they can't just
wait it out they have to go back to
their country of origin where they
started from so we're talking about
ships that were in the philippines that
are in california have to go back to the
to the philippines there's labor unions
a part of these um
trade routes that are saying please stop
with these ridiculous lockdowns with
these ridiculous restrictions they make
absolutely no sense at all the laws that
you guys have implemented here are
absolutely backwards meanwhile you have
the southern border wide open but if you
come into the united states you need a
negative test the word
quarantine actually comes from it's
italian from the 1660s uh a ship
suspected of carrying a contagious
disease would have to wait in port for
40 days the quarantine
interesting
yeah you guys have seen the episode of
seinfeld where george castanza decides
to do the opposite of what he normally
does
it's almost like that's that's joe biden
but we're trying like he's like
you know do do the opposite of what what
so everything goes wrong the ports are
all backed up but the borders wide open
drug cartels are smuggling drugs in but
we can't get our christmas toys that's
right
why why
the one thing that should be here can't
and the one thing that's not supposed to
be here is yeah talk about a guy doing
the opposite of what's what's supposed
to be happening hunter biden is happy
though he's getting uh whatever he wants
so
again we talked about his uh approval
numbers and we said it's probably the
taliban it's probably the cartel members
that are the ones that are saying we're
very happy with what's happening right
now because everyone else is just
looking around and i think a lot of
people are ashamed that they even voted
for biden i'm not seeing anyone support
joe biden i'm not seeing anyone make any
defenses except for uh sellouts who get
hired to do it whether it's influencers
actors they're the only ones publicly
supporting they're having a hard time
even pulling that off it's punk rock
again yeah now that joe biden's approval
rating is in the gutter it is once again
punk rock to oppose
joe to to don't support support to
support joe biden yes because now most
people don't like him
so uh now that most people don't like
him i am uh i actually like him oh okay
cause i'm i'm i'm punk rock what do you
like most about him his eyes
his hair
his beady eyes that barely barely are up
dude
i like his grubby little hands
cheering for biden is so mainstream man
it was it was for a long time i wonder
now what will happen now that people are
starting to hate him will celebrities
now be like
joe biden sucks
the question for me is
just just looking at how how the
politics of this are shaping up biden
was brought in on a wave of anybody but
trump
i wonder what is going to happen
if trump throws his hat back in the ring
i don't know what trump is going to do
but suppose trump throws his hat back
into the ring
now you people are going to get to say
okay we're going to trump can run on his
record and joe biden is going to run on
his record and i wonder what that looks
like
how
what what media environment does that
create what new levels of inauthenticity
will the media reach what new levels of
fakery will show up when you all of a
sudden
because when biden was running it was
always he was
basically running on obama's record i
was obama's vice president
therefore
everyone goes okay well how were the
years jeering obama well that i guess
maybe wasn't the worst thing in the
world and they hate trump so fine they
can pull the lever for biden now biden
has a track record
now people get to look at biden and say
this is what we're going to vote for
four more years of
now they'll take trump yeah we're seeing
trump support go up in a lot of key
areas i want to correct you a little bit
because biden wasn't running the media
was running for biden and biden was
literally in a basement and they were
keeping him there making sure he wasn't
out there to the general public so so
now the media is even questioning biden
and and being like wait wait wait hold
on
what do we have on our hands here we
have a president that doesn't even want
to talk to us that literally says he's
going to get in trouble if he gives us
the comment yeah we're having record low
ratings we're we're showing for a guy
that that literally doesn't even know
what's going on doesn't even know where
he is that literally created one of the
worst disasters in geopolitical history
with afghanistan and they're looking
around at the utter chaos and
devastation and i think even a lot of
people in the media are going to have a
very hard time shilling for him again in
2024 and i don't think he's going to be
running i think it's i think he's not
going to be the candidate it's
impossible with the havoc that he is
wrecking on the american people it'd be
too good it would it would it would be
too too good for uh the republicans and
for the for the anti-establishment so
they need to pull him out and then get
some kind of do-over with but i i i
don't know honestly i don't even know
who to name who who is harrison no no no
no no one likes her she's worse than
she's like yeah she's like hillary but
worse
some people like biden
who likes biden but i guess i'm not like
like 13 of the
population now hold on there a minute
and let me ask you a question
if someone came to you and told you that
they liked say uh giordano's deep dish
pizza it's good right now i'm listening
yeah but what if you then ask them when
was the last time they had it they said
oh i've never actually had it oh would
you believe that no i would prefer not
to hang out with that person but you'd
be like how could you say you like
giordano's deep dish pizza if you've
never actually i think i know people
like that where they're like yeah like
you like that they're like yeah yeah
exactly exactly so when you say some
people like biden i'm like you're
correct but it's just like that they
don't know anything about them they
haven't followed the news they don't
know her care it's just
yeah oh yeah like you know whatever he
is not trump and we just we just pull
out the old post-modern analysis of of
of joe biden and say they're not voting
for biden they're voting for the symbol
of what biden represents they're voting
for the media created image of what
biden would be
if he was actually in charge and running
things we need it we need a comic about
this yeah we're like there's the media's
version of joe biden have you ever seen
uh ben garrison's version of trump yeah
oh my god he's like ripped and he's like
got a strong chicken
yeah come on please glorious uh and and
i still voted for the guy but i
recognize that's not that's not trump
trump walks like a duck and he's
overweight he's been doing better yeah
he's lost
but i would love a comic of like joke
the media's version of joe biden like
the joe biden that exists in the hearts
of minds of hearts and minds of the most
zealot democrats he's like ripped and
chiseled with his aviator sunglasses in
a leather jacket and he's in a
convertible and he's like get in loser
we're saving america and they're like
yay when in reality he's like he can't
speak and he touches kids
yeah well didn't they do a magazine
cover where he was wearing his super
cool aviators and everyone was just like
what is this like we all see this feeble
decrepit old man you guys are trying to
tell us that he's some kind of superhero
but barack obama was right when he said
you should never underestimate joe
biden's um
ability to mess things up i love it i
love i love the people who are like
remember oh obama's only scandal was a
town suit oh my and there are people who
are just like it's like the pizza thing
the people who are just like they'll say
yes i like whatever you say so they all
laugh along and go yeah yeah tan suit
and then i'm just like you remember when
obama killed that kid that american kid
in a civilian restaurant in yemen like
and other civilians yeah you don't want
to talk about scandals operation fast
and furious oh
spying scandal and a safe scandal war on
whistleblowers going after spying on
merkel journalists and whistleblowers
more than any other president before him
with this one particular law i forgot
the name of it the spanish the espionage
yeah more than all other presidents
combined exactly so like there's so many
things to talk about the biden
presidency and a lot of people who have
said that
biden presidency is a continuation of an
obama presidency and there might be some
merit to that but this would be kind of
an unmasked obama uh push that literally
is just the perfect representation of
everything globalists ever wanted it's
their epitome of their wet dream when it
comes to when when you see what they're
able to achieve a lot of people are
saying oh it was just a mistake oh this
is you know there's just an accident i i
think when you're at that high level of
government i think when you have that
much money that much power i think they
they play things off as as accidents and
mistakes when in reality a lot of this
stuff was deliberate and when you look
at whose interest it serves who it helps
it's usually the people backing these
individuals it's usually the dark money
it's usually a lot of the people that
are behind the scenes that usually are
very influential in governments but
they're the ones that don't get voted on
they don't get elected but they're still
there the bureaucratic state exactly
um
i just i just sent uh
lydia the uh there's a there's a comic
book where they made a comic of hillary
clinton oh my gosh yeah
yeah i forgot about this yeah they did
the superhero we didn't know we needed
[Music]
yeah we knew we didn't want her i'm
gonna we don't deserve or need yeah let
me pull this story from timcast.com this
is you may have heard the news governor
abbott bars vaccine mandates in texas
the state's legislature previously
banned local governments and school
districts from requiring vaccines or
masks this is big it's that simple
now joe biden's executive order
for
uh the osha rule 100 employees or more
it's not it doesn't exist it was just a
press conference it's not there there's
no executive voter on the books and osha
has not implemented this rule however
abbott is saying in texas you cannot you
cannot have vaccine mandates southwest
is based in dallas
so what are they going to do are they
going to you know so what are they gonna
now if they do this they're gonna get
fined i guess per per employer or
however it worked a thousand bucks but
think about this what happens if osha
does drop this rule
let's say you're a business in texas
and you're told by the governor if you
mandate vaccines for your employees or
customers we will fine you a thousand
bucks per in fraction but then you get
the fed saying if you don't we will find
you way more per infraction
so do you think this is why the
southwest ceo is saying what he's saying
about not liking vaccine mandates or
mass mandates or whatever he's got he
can't do anything about it i mean you
got a look
i just got to slow down pick a side
that's where we're at pick a side yeah
that's what bothers me this is an
example of fighting authoritarianism
with authoritarianism what abbott did i
think is a step too far he he basically
mandated that no one can authorize
vaccines he's telling the private
companies
he's saying so so the federal government
said everyone has to do it then abbott
set in and came in and said no one's
allowed to do it and you know why what
he said already along the book saying
you can't discriminate for medical
reasons so what he should have said is
you don't have to listen to the federal
government you can do whatever you want
no the the mandate specifically says
that individuals are allowed exemptions
for religious personal conscience or or
medical reasons
so this is what's effectively shutting
down the vaccine minutes that people can
just choose not to get them due to
personal conscience there's already laws
in the book saying you can't
discriminate for medical or religious
reasons as far as i can tell and correct
me if i'm wrong abbott's telling every
private company in texas that they're
not allowed to mandate vaccines now
should they be allowed to uh
ban people if they're black
i don't know i don't think so why or if
they're in a civil rights law yeah or if
they're in a wheelchair should should
they be allowed to ban wheelchairs
or people without aids or camps well it
depends on the job you know certain
things require certain amounts of
activity so like if you need someone to
climb ladders you can't hire someone in
wheelchairs but that's that's a form of
discrimination
so if you need somebody to
uh work in a grocery store
and there are jobs that can be done in a
grocery store that someone in a
wheelchair can do should they be allowed
to say no wheelchairs allowed
what about what about a muslim person
should they be like no no i get that
muslim stuff out here i should be able
to they think that violates civil rights
yes and there's also the the amer uh the
ada the americans with disabilities act
so now you've got medical reasons and we
shouldn't have to present our papers to
our doc
to the store to prove
should a person who's got some kind of
like uh not you know should someone have
to go and prove that they're the right
race and they say oh you know i'm not
firing you because of your race because
you i don't even know if that's your
real race the [ __ ] they have to go and
go pull up lineage no you don't got to
prove it we just make the case when we
complain the point is i i i agree to an
excerpt to a certain extent abbot should
we shouldn't have rule by decree
however these are different situations
if the law already states you can't
discriminate for religious reasons and
medical reasons and it does
case close yeah if someone says it is
against my deeply held moral and and
spiritual and religious or whatever
beliefs
they should be yeah but you don't have
to hire someone with leprosy if they
come in there that's different what's
different about it i mean come on bro i
mean it's different to me because we pay
attention but you know in the mind of a
business owner who's who's the governor
to say who they can and can't that's a
different question because in one case
you're asking about somebody who already
has a disease and the second case you're
asking about not whether someone has a
disease but whether or not they've been
vaccinated not whether or not they're
sick so in the case of the leprosy thing
you'd say well you already have it you
can give it to somebody whereas in the
case of the vaccine thing do you have
covid no i don't have government not too
bad
why because you're not vaccinated
right that's this that's the uh that's
the separation point what i would ask is
whether or not for all the people who
are pushing the covet thing
could a bar owner say nobody with stds
is allowed to come to ladies night
we want we want couples to get together
and you got to bring your
papers you have to disclose to us your
hiv status would people be comfortable
with that of course they wouldn't or or
would people be comfortable saying look
you have to have your vaccine for hep c
before you can come in would people be
comfortable with that
for me the question is how far can these
things get pushed
and
i understand
vax passports i understand why people
want them but the
the question that no one has been able
to ask to answer for me is
where is the hard and fast line that it
stops no one's been able to give me an
answer to that and that's why i'm so
skeptical of them let's add another
element here let's talk about this you
know vaccine that stops stds the vaccine
that stops this hypothetical that we're
talking about doesn't stop stds it
doesn't prevent the spread of stds it
doesn't stop people from having stds as
well on top of all of this which people
need to understand the greater point
here so so you know there's so many
different ways that people could take
this there's if we're starting to
discriminate against people because of
their medical personal choices and
decisions you know let's first discuss
that and even on those merits whether
the you know the effective see of the
vaccine the transmission of the vaccine
natural immunity i think that
conversation needs to happen in this
first place the second thing is no one
should be telling me what to do a
government shouldn't be controlling
every aspect of my existence because
because if they could do this with the
vaccine they could do this with almost
every other aspect of our existence and
abbott's basically telling business
owners what to do he's saying you can
sign an executive order saying that
vaccine mandates are not allowed by any
entity right so it's a form of
authoritarianism now maybe he did the
right thing i disagree because he's
standing up for people's civil rights
he's standing up for people's personal
decisions he's standing up to the
current kind of hipaa laws that are out
there that says that people can't be
discriminated against and have to
divulge their medical history any time
already uh evident he doesn't need to
mandate civil rights to people he just
needs to protect them from his
government's overreach south southwest
is literally violating
social norms and law
and they can go work at a different
texas i mean this is the i think it
starts to break down is when it's a when
it's a national company with with a
satellite in texas this is this is this
is really interesting because we did
have this conversation before it may
have been with michael malus the the
argument you're making is the argument
that was made by by conservatives and uh
maybe conservatives at the right word
but it was made by the the democrats to
stop civil rights they said the
government should not have the authority
to mandate a private business
you know
not discriminated they can serve
whatever they want if someone doesn't
want to work there or someone go they
don't have to go there that was always
the argument
then you had the the social uh you know
people fighting for civil rights
specifically saying public
accommodations are shared by all if
we're all paying taxes into it then we
should all be able to utilize these
services my view of it is if there is
limited space in the commons
and there is a building occupying space
in that commons and my tax dollars go
towards infrastructure plumbing fire
department ems and all that they should
not be allowed to discriminate against
me or anybody else
on specific grounds that of course we
need to sort through an outline now we
have outlines many of them religious
reasons you can't put up a sign saying
no muslims allowed
you can't mandate that people eat bacon
to enter your store because that would
very serious someone walk in i mean
maybe you can but then if someone who
was muslim walked up and they said do it
you'd be like you can't do that that's
discrimination on the basis of my
religion and you'd probably get in
trouble there's a guy who went to jail
for throwing bacon at a mosque
so so right now abbott is basically
saying
these these mandates just violate so
many of our non-discrimination laws you
can't do this public accommodation is
for all if we are paying taxes into it
we are a community to maintain social
cohesion you cannot restrict access to
someone on the basis of their medical
reasons or religious reasons or personal
moral conscious reasons now it's tough
it is because personal moral conscience
is a broad term but he said that in his
executive order because it's basically
about religion there's a lot of people
who are saying oh but the pope said they
can get the vaccine even though it's you
they use fetal cells to make it in the
testing process and it's other vaccines
they literally use it and isn't testing
for a bunch of other medicines the
public says it's fine well i don't care
what the pope thinks and i'm sure
there's a whole lot of other catholics
who don't care that the pope has said
that they're like no that that goes
against our religious but values
so if we already have the laws on the
books
than him simply saying hey guys i am
reinforcing that you cannot discriminate
so i guess we're all in agreement that
sometimes authoritarianism is necessary
and good no that's what abbot just did
no
hold on hold on there a minute you mean
decades of civil rights work to get laws
put on the books through legislation and
elected representatives who then voted
on it is authoritarianism no i'm saying
him making a decree like this is
authoritarian making a decree to
reinstate to to to reaffirm what is all
just like just like desegregating
schools that was authoritarianism you
can see how it works sometimes
desegregating schools was the part of a
long process resulted in a republic
having a vote on an issue
so authoritarianism was when everyone
just falls in line and adheres to the
authority like the cult
when people have strong objections and
and and disagreements and then we say
hey we all have finally agreed this is
the line
you have to you can't discriminate and
it was through a democratic
representative process
sure you can argue that people are oh no
they have to adhere to the authority of
the state because we all agreed to it
but there's a big difference between we
fought long and hard we won over hearts
and minds we got our elected
representatives put in office they voted
for it then the supreme court upheld it
and now we're at a point where the
governor is saying guys the law is clear
you can't do this i am not going to
allow you to because as the head of the
executive branch of my state i am here
to enforce the laws that already exist
that's not authoritarianism joe biden
issuing an edict where he convinces
people there's along the books when
there isn't and they all start following
him that's authoritarianism it's both
it's just two two governors making
declarations about what to do telling
people what they can and can't do wait
wait is your objection that is your
objection that it was made by the
governor and not by the state
legislature definitely okay firstly and
secondly i don't like the government
telling private companies what they can
and can't do i'm very nervous and
reticent about that kind of thing so i
noticed it when it happened
i i don't think this is authoritarianism
ian i think this is simply him
reinforcing the fact that we have civil
rights and that no one should have the
right to require someone to get a
medical procedure if they don't want it
this has always been the case this is
just him reminding everyone that this is
the case and not he's not even
necessarily putting anything new into
effect
let me ask another question if uh if a
bunch of businesses in texas started
banning black people and then he issued
an executive order saying the banning of
black people is prohibited would you
call that authoritarianism
yeah but there's already a law in the
book through a democratic process
well him saying something
is different than disease um you know
you can suspend habeas corpus in times
of great disease
i mean you maybe can as obviously you
can but
i i don't think it's not about disease
it's about vaccination
if this was about if
there's nothing in there that prevents
a company from saying we'd like you to
take a rapid antigen covert test before
you enter our business represent a rapid
energy and cover test we don't want
anyone with covid but that's not what
that's about this is about vaccination
not disease and i think there's a
dividing line there if a business wants
to say look we're only going to have
people coming who have tested negative
for covert i would say
all right well if you want to make
everyone take an antigen test before
they come in or present an antigen just
i guess you want to do that that's fine
but there's a difference between saying
you have to give us an uh an antigen
test so that we know whether you have
covert or not we're keeping the covet
out not you on the one hand or on the
other hand say
only if you're vaccinated because then i
mean think of the the absurdity that
comes in the guy who says i've tested
negative for covet i don't have covet i
can't go in another guy says i tested
positive for government but i'm faxed
see you all there
and many people who do take the vaccine
do test positive yeah so uh someone with
a breakthrough case can go in with covet
in a cough all over everywhere because
they're vaccinated and someone who's not
who's not sick doesn't have covalent is
tested negative can't go in because he's
not vaccinated right this is not about
disease it's about using the withdrawal
of the ability to use services as a
cudgel to beat people who aren't getting
vaccinated and that's i think a
difference and i want to break this down
what we're seeing at the federal level
with binding the democrats versus texas
with joe biden on multiple occasions now
he said the legislative legislature be
damned i will exact executive decree on
the evicted moratorium and now with the
with the osha rule those things need to
go through the congress we also have the
supreme court saying no to him with the
eviction moratorium and him being like
don't care i'll do it anyway and he did
and then democrats cheered for it abbott
is saying guys there are laws in the
book saying you can't do this and i am
obligated to enforce those i am telling
you right now this cannot be done as per
existing law florida
yeah florida's doing a similar thing
saying you can't discriminate against
someone you can't force them to do this
especially if they have religious
exemptions a judge in new in new york
just upheld religious exemptions for
health care workers so legal leads
right now this is being decided in the
high courts and a lot of people are
siding with you have a right not to
comply with this mandate that they're
trying to force on you and this is
something that's you know imperative
this is something that's important this
is something that provides people
liberties and freedoms that historically
throughout life they never really had
ever uh and now uh they're finally given
this ability that's slowly being
eradicated slowly being taken away from
them and people are saying no this is
just absolutely ridiculous this is over
the top this is draconian this is
totalitarian and people trying to stand
up against it are not using that same
kind of force and energy uh they're
trying to stop a lot of that
intrusion into our personal lives
yeah we have the story from gothamist
actually courtside with new york health
care workers seeking religious
exemptions reject vaccine appeal by nyc
teachers they report that new york can't
stop hospital and nursing home workers
from seeking religious exemptions to the
state's covet 19 vaccine mandate a
federal judge ruled tuesday requiring
workers to get vaccinated without
allowing such exemptions conflicts with
long-standing federal protections for
religious beliefs judge david hurd of
the u.s district court of the northern
district of new york wrote in his
decision the policy requiring all
hospital nursing nursing home and home
care staff to get vaccinated against
kovid was initially issued under cuomo
we get the point point is the law
already exists and it's clear you can't
do that it's not authoritarian when we
fought long and hard had elected
representatives vote on something that's
literally a constitutional republic
process
joe biden being like nah don't care
cuomo being like so what don't care
cuomo with the law on the book saying
you couldn't do this said i hereby
decree that's authoritarianism
yeah when you look at the implications
of both of these policies you clearly
see one where we have government agents
intruding into people's lives punishing
them taking something away uh and and
issuing fines
for
not going through another hoop that they
literally made up uh that hoop is a very
important one it's it's a very big one
and it has a lot of big implications
because if the government could do this
people could argue based on health
policy they could also do it to obese
people and fat people because of the
same kind of health guidelines for the
greater good of everyone the governor
bloomberg wants
centralized government arguing for the
greater good of everyone it's it's
literally the recipe for disaster all
throughout human history and it's being
repeated now by individuals saying yeah
you know fighting back against it is is
futile it's bad as well it's not do you
guys think that vaccine mandates are
unconstitutional across the board
no
what's the instance where it's not so
there there have been certain there are
certain circumstances where
i think vaccines can be mandated but
what you need to understand is that
there's also a scale of acceptable risk
meaning if you've got an airborne ebola
with a 50 mortality rate you're not
gonna have to worry about anything
people are gonna be panicking and
begging to be a part of the vaccination
program but we're dealing with covid
which is serious and long covert is
serious and i i don't know the exact
percentages but you know we don't want
people to get sick and die at the same
time the the the rate for individuals
healthy under the age of 40 is
substantially lower so we're dealing
with a nuanced political circumstance
that being said there there are some
times like in the military for instance
they've mandated tons of vaccines the
difference here with covet is that it's
new and um you know i i talked about
this quite a bit when you join the
military they you know when you're in
basic training they give you a whole
bunch of vaccines you can require
certain vaccines for travel for certain
work right so when i was traveling to
like venezuelan egypt yellow fever
vaccination is a requirement because it
was an insurance requirement and this is
different this is the company saying
we're not firing you we're just telling
you like if you want to be the guy who
gets to go to venezuela like yo you got
to get you got a yellow fever shot and
so i did and i went to the doctor and he
gave me this shot and it was i think the
yellow fever one hurt no i was the
yellow favorite one i don't know one of
them goes in your skin it sucks that i
understand subcutaneously but if you're
going to say
a public accommodation
buying a sandwich
with on on a street that you you are
obligated to pay for right we all know
how luke feels about taxation i think
it's just from barely it's just for
employees no in new york the mandates
are you can't even go inside italy yeah
so that's the other thing too let's okay
let's let's talk about employers first
of all for for the regular for a regular
person it shouldn't be allowed but let's
talk about healthcare workers seeking
religious exemptions you know these
hospitals receive public funding that's
my understanding right they're on public
streets so you're telling me i have to
pay for it and then you're banning me
from using it because of what i my
religion no we already have a law saying
you can't discriminate in the basis of
religion now there's reasonable
reasonable exemptions to that like if
you believe in sacrificing goats not
gonna let you do it in public like in
the middle of the street and 50 ebola
death then damn your religion and take
it anyway see the the difference there
is
when we're dealing with issues of like
viruses that aren't all identical people
have different expectations for the
risks they're facing with kovid it is
clear that there's a large percentage of
people who don't believe the risk is
warrants a sacrifice of such great loss
of freedoms when it came to the civil
war people are like abraham lincoln did
a good thing and you know in in in
fighting the war slavery needed to be
ended there's a great moral injustice
and so people need i've talked about
this before that we all are trying to
figure out where the line is and what
we're willing to accept when we take
certain actions
when it comes to an airborne ebola like
people's insides are being liquefied
we're like yo
we got to do something about this and if
you're looking at a 20 mortality rate
and a vaccine that has like a 0.01 risk
factor most people are going to be like
i'll take it but when you're dealing
with this there's one report saying that
the the risk factor for some for for a
ch a boy under
uh there's one study that came out
saying the myocarditis was a greater it
was a higher percentage risk than
getting coveted itself some studies
showing eight times higher i i don't
know if that's one study is good enough
to say definitively that's why i tell
people go talk to a doctor and figure it
out talk to someone who knows about it
yeah right and get second opinions the
point is
when it comes to issues of what we're
willing to give up our freedoms for
there are some things i think most
people recognize if an alien invasion
happened man there's a really tough
question about what we need to do to
rally everyone together to survive
if it's like
you know
a series of crimes
and it's in one city why should the
people of new york mandate everyone in
the country lose their right to bear
arms because of the crimes in their city
that's basically what's happening i have
i think what's happening also is that
there's a segment of people that are
like hey kovid we look at the numbers it
doesn't look that that dangerous is what
people are making it out to be so this
seems like it's unconstitutional you've
gone too far but then there's other
people that won't leave their house
because they're afraid for their life
and so for for abbott to tell everyone
in texas you can't mandate it even
though they might feel like afraid for
their life
is where i was like well there's the
authoritarian flag i'm not saying he's
wrong i'm just saying
but i i think you bring up a good point
i think i think regardless of whether or
not this is very to the disease no one
should have to uh give up their freedom
for someone else's fear and that means
even if there is an airborne ebola you
can choose to go get vaccinated for it
and other people who don't well then
that's their issue i suppose and we
should be operating on a more you know
liberty-minded and personal response we
need personal responsibility and liberty
even in the face of something like an
airborne ebola look man if there was an
airborne ebola 50 mortality people's
insides were liquefying i would go to
the mountains
like i'm not going to go anywhere you
think that'll help you escape those kind
of things if you ever watch the stand
you would know sure sure it's a movie
and in this instance the risk is there
we don't you know the people who are
over here with with covet people over 40
are higher risk people that are obese
so what do we do
do we just
we destroy everything i mean economies
in shambles people are going hungry
people around the world are starving
we're seeing massive ripple effects it's
affecting everything
unless people want a great reset i think
at a certain point you recognize that we
need to strip look ultimately i'll say
it like this you know what i i do not
support the vaccine mandates however
if there were a legislative body that
voted
and there were long-term
studies
and then specific exemptions i'd be like
okay well it was done through an
electoral process
having governors and the president just
declare by edict i'm like no way
absolutely not when we talk about you
know vaccines like for mmr at schools
and stuff i'm like yeah but these are
vaccines that have been around
researched for decades they've been
around for even longer than that a lot
of these vaccines went through very
serious and rigorous studies over over
seriously 20 to 30 years now when it
comes to the the covet vaccine operation
warp speed it's the one of the fastest
projects ever done
i don't think personally
a lot of people think that there's like
you know the vaccine is dangerous i
don't i don't think that i think
ultimately my opinion is irrelevant so
i'm not a doctor i just think people's
medical choices are their own
if people have a sincere medical uh
religious belief like imagine if
imagine if de blasio said you have to
eat bacon
like everybody must eat bacon right now
like you'd have a whole lot of religious
people being up in arms like you can't
do that
so there's a similar thing there i'll
tell you this though there it is a fair
point absolutely to say the lines
between what we're willing to accept are
different for everybody and there are
some people who are staunchly
libertarian and even if there was an
airborne zombie virus would be like you
cannot force me to do anything no matter
what and there would be other people who
were like seemingly libertarian before
now being like at this point lock
everyone in their houses
so i think everybody has their line how
much risk you're willing to associate
it's it's on it's a gradient scale and
to make laws as a white or a black or a
yes or no or a one or a zero that's it's
that's tough however be a personal
decision but when it comes to what
abbott is saying like i thought about
this i said this before i'm like i don't
like the idea that you know desantis was
like nobody can ben nobody can mandate
masks and i'm like let's should go to
the legislature right however
you know masks are different from the
vaccine thing the mass thing i think is
interesting if somebody wants to require
a mask in their store like what's your
justification for saying that they can't
require shirts or they can't they have
they can require shirts vaccines
different it's a it's an irreversible
medical procedure and there are people
with medical issues over the fetal cell
use and there are people with medical
issues with religious issues over the
fetal values and medical issues that
i think you can't force it i have
religious problems with it personally i
i it violates everything i hold dear to
my my my spirit i
i will not touch it no i i would never i
would never in a million years feel
right taking a rushed vaccine with the
evidence i have and that is a religion
that is my true belief in what i am
i so i mean i never defined my religion
but that's how so let's put this
conscience yeah do you think that you
have a right to public accommodation in
the comments no you don't think oh in
the commons
i mean yeah yeah my through my tax
dollars yeah right so do you think then
abbott sang guys this guy's paying taxes
you can't kick him out
is that authoritarianism
because if i start violating their
semblance of normality and then he's
like you still can't get rid of them but
this is this is something you pay for
with your taxes yeah for them to tell
you that you have no access to these
spaces would be them stealing from you i
guess i get access but it's up to me to
to maintain dignity to stay there like
if i pull my pants down then then right
so so then i i would say this
the question that i have about the
vaccine mandate is if they're going to
say well you have to have a vaccine
mandate why don't them come along and
say okay a vaccine or a negative covid
test
and it's the lack of or a negative cova
test that knocks it out for me because
if you said or a negative cova test that
would mean that the
mandate was really about
coven the fact that there's no
or a negative covid test means they're
just wanting everyone to be vaccinated
come hell or high water
so again this leaves us in the absurd
scenario where someone who has coveted
but is vaccinated can go into a
restaurant and
breathe as much as they want and someone
who can prove that they don't have covet
is kicked out right that's the absurdity
that that the vax mandates and the vax
passport that's what that's what gets me
if you can say
or i mean where i live it's
of you have to show vaxx proof of
vaccination or a negative cova test and
the anti-didn't covet tests are going
for like 200 bucks a pop people people
want them but that you can do that you
can say still it's still
there's still a problem there in that
man what they're mandating at some
universities like every three days oh
who's got the time no to go and do that
and spend that money so then people just
go fine screw it i'll do whatever you
say and that's and that's the problem so
that that's a good a good moral
conundrum though the ebola thing like
what everyone's rights are be damned if
this if the virus is severe enough
perhaps and then the issue is you're
right the democrats are terrified
they're shaken and then they really are
we look at the polls
look at what happened when we invited uh
hassan [ __ ] on the show
and he was like i'm totally down i'll do
it and then he was like yo i'm kind of
worried about kofit we have people here
all the time who are kind of like we
wash our hands we use hand sanitizer we
take precautions we clean everything you
know and and we we we're actually i
think we're actually socially distanced
right now we are
probably
socially distance at this table and uh
but we we have to live our lives man so
uh no disrespect to son he's genuinely
concerned about this but his concern is
is several orders of magnitude more than
ours
you know what i mean
so then if he's going to vote for what
he wants lockdowns and we're going to
refuse that
i don't know and maybe the real simple
solution is if you're scared you stay
home you know the beauty of the united
states is that each state is uh is an
experiment and this is an opportunity to
watch it happen in texas and see if that
if i maybe maybe on this side
misusing authoritarianism i know it's
not an extreme authoritative thing what
he did but this is an opportunity to see
if what he's doing works i mean the
experiment was there in sweden it was
there in florida it was there in many
places around the world that said we're
not going to be playing ball there's a
lot of other experiments right now
happening in places like norway just
released a lot of their restrictions
their lockdowns their mandates masks all
of that their case numbers went down so
there's so many examples of of
experiments i always said from the
beginning of this sweden's going to be
the true test of this because if you
remember they were saying that sweden's
going to end up in a bloodbath there's
going to be bodies stacking on top of
bodies there's going to be a massacre of
unprecedented proportions everyone's
going to die in sweden because somehow
sweden's not following along with the
programming they're not going along what
they're told to do by the by the world
economic forum by the world health
organization by a lot of these quote
experts and look what happened to sweden
look at their numbers compare their
numbers to the states that lock down the
most compare their numbers to israel and
singapore and you will truly have your
eyes opened why
wide by the disparity of numbers
actually i think i think we have a good
story for this topic and and what ian's
talking about let me pull this up this
is from sf gate walgreens is closing
five san francisco stores due to
organized retail crime
they say they give the addresses i'm not
going to read the addresses but they're
going to close close five more stores a
company spokesperson confirmed tuesday
setting ongoing organized retail crime
is the reason organized retail crime
continues to be a challenge facing
retailers across san francisco and we
are not immune to that
retail theft across our san francisco
stores has continued to increase in the
past few months to five times our chain
average during this time to help combat
the issue we increased our investments
in security measures in stores across
the city to 46 times our chain average
in an effort to provide a safe
environment
we also heard target i believe it was is
going to change their hours because they
can't handle all of the theft
there's an interesting conundrum here
you've got in new york city right aoc
they want to do away with cash bail
i actually agree uh i i do i think that
if someone is accused of a crime
non-violent of course
and they're poor holding them and
demanding cash for them to leave is is
punishing someone who can't afford it so
we we have we're innocent until proven
guilty you can't hold me in lock up
before you've proven anything i'm
innocent
and so there's a really serious problem
then they started releasing repeat
offenders who are laughing as they were
committing these crimes you then take a
look at what's going on in san francisco
yeah they're overly lacked with what's
happening and now you're getting
businesses pulling out
so what's the answer more cops to arrest
people stop stop and frisk or the
government backs off
personal responsibility
how do you solve a problem like this
stop disarming people stop taking away
their ability to defend themselves you
fight back in new york city against
someone who is a clear aggressor and
attacker you will be going to jail
that's an absolutely absurd law that
creates more victims creates less
personal responsibility and creates a
situation where criminals thrive
criminals literally have
the carte blanche many times in new york
city to do whatever they want because
there's many instances of police
officers just standing back watching
crimes happen
watching people get hurt and they're
saying well i'm having an argument with
the government so i'm just not going to
do anything
you know they'll arrest you in two
seconds if you've got a gun though
they'll rest you in two seconds if you
have a political sign in the wrong place
and you're saying the wrong message uh
as well so there's been many instances
of businesses that got shut down by by
you know police officers by sheriffs uh
all throughout new york city because
they just wanted to have their business
open meanwhile uh black lives matter
protests even on fox news cops standing
around the corner with their arms uh you
know hugging themselves as businesses
are being alluded and the cops are just
standing there so you think like the the
store owners should be armed and fire no
i believe in personal responsibility and
if you're going to be incentivizing
people to get away with crimes you
should incentivize people to defend
themselves and to be able to not be
victims of those crimes i guess the
theft is a non-violent crime so it's
tough to authorize like a store owner
if someone's stealing something right in
front of you right out of your hands i
mean there's an argument that's to be
made but out of your store like if
you're a store owner and they were
robbing your shelves it's not really
ethical to fire your weapon at them um
so
i struggle with this idea that i have to
restrict myself to the amount of force
that's being used i mean i'm not
necessarily sure if someone comes into
my store and starts taking my things out
that it you know i have to say restrict
myself to in in the amount of force i
use to put a stop to that
for example
i don't think it would be fair to say
well
you're a lot bigger than that guy is so
you'll have to find someone smaller to
tackle that thief
i don't i don't think that that that
that's a good ethical principle now that
said
i also don't think that
because because what you're saying this
this is how that's going to turn out
someone's going to be like stealing a
package of lip gloss and some guy's
going to open fire with a shotgun
of what happens is i i i think that's
acceptable um and and i'll just say
sorry to interrupt but uh if someone is
committing a crime in your store
this is one of the things you learn
right away when it comes to home defense
people you know you had dave chappelle
who was like he did that stand up bit
where he's like you know bird shot bird
shot buckshot bird shot buckshot and
everyone i talked to says absolutely not
buckshot buckshot buckshot buckshot
buckshot because you don't know that
person breaking into your house
if you point a weapon at them they could
end you and if someone is in your store
committing a crime and you think it's
just lip gloss i'll be nice to them and
they pull out a revolver or whatever
there's that uh that that video went
viral of the cop just just recently he's
outside taking the guy out of the car
and the dude pulls out a rifle and just
starts shooting at him yeah so so the
difficulty is i i think the point you're
making is
restricting someone's use of force
i i certainly think that if somebody is
committing a crime you should be able to
use force to stop them to protect
yourself because you don't know to what
extent
right i mean crime is rising it's very
tough it's there's no universal answer
but i think it's clear that crime is
rising where crime is allowed where
prosecutors aren't going after people
where police officers are looking the
other way and i think there's also other
societies that are polite societies that
they know a lot of people are armed a
lot of people are willing to defend
themselves and there's an effect knowing
that hey
there's a responsibility here that is
known by everyone that if you do cross a
certain line there are ramifications
that you will have to pay for those
specific lines and i think the more
people are able to assert themselves the
less aggressors they would have against
them and things there would be less harm
there would be less violence there would
be less crime there would be less people
hurt overall
in the long run uh than if in the
current system that we have right now i
don't mean to do rally though so no the
point i'm getting though is a big one
about institutional trust
if you don't trust the cops to enforce
the laws if you think that the cops are
actually going to make things worse
which is a number of what people from i
don't know black lives matter might
argue that the cops make things worse
when that when that institutional trust
in the prosecutorial system in the jail
system in the uh police system degrades
and erodes and people start removing
that away and the ability for cops to
[Music]
enforce the law goes the incentive
structure is such that someone's going
to say look i'm going to run into the
store i can just go with my duffel bag
and go through the jewelry section and
just you know five to ten of us will
just go in and then walk out and if
you're not going to prosecute crimes say
under a thousand dollars or under 500
because it's not worth it it
incentivizes those crimes because the
guy's gonna say well what are you gonna
do about it there's five of us
so
so what needs to happen is you you have
to be able to bring about a situation
where the police are able to enforce the
law without abusing the authority given
them to enforce the law and that's the
difficult point because on the one hand
there's an awful lot of people and i
think that i mean i think i would get
some sympathy for me and with this to
say man have you seen how some cops
behave when they're enforcing the law
the way that they they treat citizens um
the way people are treated in prisons i
mean it's absolutely abhorrent but if
you say well because of that we're going
to take away the cop's power to be able
to arrest people and we're going to try
and reduce
people's engagement with law enforcement
under those circumstances by taking away
police power all of a sudden
there's now no incentive for somebody
not to rob a store and so i see this as
in large part as a function of the
destruction of the
trust in the institutions that are
enforcing justice so now what's
happening is that
uh on the one hand the the police were
viewed to have gone too far and in
places like san francisco seattle's
another one that has a huge problem
people said no we don't want the police
doing that we don't want the police
defund the police defund the police to
fund the police to fund the police pull
the police back we are now seeing the
fruit of those seeds beginning to bloom
in the disorder and the chaos
so is i thought it was an interesting
question then the on levels of
acceptable authoritarianism right as it
were police are allowed to stop you
detain you ask you questions and they
make an arrest based on you know if they
believe you've committed a crime
and sometimes they're wrong and then as
people get locked up and so there's that
big challenge you know ben franklin said
it is better than 100 guilty persons
escaped than one innocent person suffer
taking from blackstone's formulation of
10 guilty persons so at what where do we
draw the line well as you mentioned when
we say you know what the cops are going
too far okay now your stores are closing
down because they're losing money right
all right well then bring the cops back
in okay now you're getting reports of
cops you know injuring people and
arresting old women like would ben
franklin say it's it's better that ten
thousand guilty people go than one
innocent suffer like where's his
threshold because he only said a hundred
i'd say ten thousand ten thousand you
know why
if people can't have confidence that in
their innocence
they will be presumed to be innocent and
will will have a hope that they will not
be falsely accused or imprisoned then
the system has no uh no they'll have no
confidence in the system at all problem
with that is 10 000 people going to
walgreens and rob 500 bucks each and
knock the business out completely
destroy the business legally well not
legally but
unprosecutorially
so maybe
man
challenges man morality is not black and
white you know it's like it's like it's
like i was saying uh i talked about this
with gender segregation and we'll
probably get into this in the members
segment where we get into this very
serious story about loudoun county which
is very very gross but um the same
arguments made today about gender
segregation were made about race
segregation back in the day we have men
and women have different rooms why are
they biologically different and they
should have their own spaces they want
to stay safe and a lot of it's a lot of
similar arguments a lot of people reject
it saying oh come on the difference
between race is marginal and and biology
is you know between men and women is
very i'm not saying one thing or another
about any biology i'm saying quite
literally the arguments people you say
back in the day that they have right
segregation because they're different
now we have gender segregation men and
women have different rooms because
they're different so the same arguments
don't fly for the same issues right
there's just there's
different than uh well they're raised
for sure there's just different things
we have different opinions about
different aspects of our existence so
it's not an easy black and white answer
there's no easy answer to a lot of these
questions there's always going to be
some kind of inequality there's always
going to be some kind of injustice but
in my own personal opinion when you get
rid of the state you get rid of a lot of
harm
that could potentially happen if you
want to reduce harm you get rid of the
state
and you leave people on personal
responsibility for for you it is it's
never going to be easy but at the end of
the day i would argue that less people
would be hurt out of that system than
they are right now i don't think so
because if you remove the state
walgreens will hire a militarized army
to go over to
you know radio shack and blow everybody
down
you're absolutely wrong
radio shack went out of business oh yeah
okay what's what's a walmart competitor
uh radio check can i ask a question
walgreens and walmart can i ask a
question of course okay so we're gonna
get rid of the state what's to stop me
from having saying well i'm going to
raise my own militia i'm going to take
over a series of land and i'm going to
own slaves i've now just created my own
mini state
the the things that power abortion is it
all comes back it's reciprocal
so my point is i don't think saying well
just getting rid of the state solves
anything i mean so i'm canadian we don't
have life liberty in the pursuit of
happiness we have peace order and good
government i think that good and
effective government is necessary as
we've seen by the shoplifting thing i
don't think anyone benefits from saying
well we're all going to have our own
personal security guards at our own
stores to combat theft um
that's that's just not and i i'm going
to upset the libertarians in the crowd
but
uh i also don't think that things like
city planning can be done in a
decentralized way and in a way that's
necessarily effective so
planning roads planning sewage um
planning electrical grids a lot of this
has to be centrally planned it's very
difficult to do if not impossible to do
in another way so
i don't think that's a solution but i do
think that
once you have a state that is not
exercising its power judiciously and
fairly and properly and competently once
you live in what we're in in a hyper
real fake
simulation or simulacra as it has to put
it um once you get into that kind of a
situation you end up with a with a
scenario where the trust in institutions
is broken and so those very institutions
that we that we institute that we create
in order to take care of of very very
important matters are not trusted and
people pull back from them they they're
going to start stepping outside the the
norms that those institutions upheld and
those things held together so what you
end up is you end up with a breakdown of
not just the
uh trust of the institutions but that
leads up to a cracking of the
organizational structure as well yeah
what was that movie with natalie porton
portman it was annihilation
yeah have you guys seen that one yeah so
i'm a spoiler alert it's not that old of
a movie but it's been out for a long
enough time there's like this weird
alien bubble when you go in dna is all
mixed and like animals have like plants
growing out of and creepy stuff's
happening and then in the end she
encounters an alien that looks just like
her and like that that's that's how i
imagine like simulacrum it's not a copy
it's a it's a cheap imitation of yeah
you know so you're saying when the state
gets too grotesque we need to or maybe
not need to but we would be good to
break it down into us into a
era of no state for a moment as we
reform a new state which is inevitable
well i think the jordan peterson's
solution is you have to burn off dead
wood
haven't you seen the meme of a v for
event the v from v for vendetta and he's
got a headphone with a microphone on it
and he says your government is doing
what have you tried turning it off and
back on again
maybe that's you know well let's go to
super chats everybody have another if
you haven't already my friend smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and go to timcast.com become a member
and you'll get access to all of our fun
and fancy members only segments of not
just this show but soon to be
tales from the inverted world and a
couple more shows working on as you
noticed we're in a new studio which
means there's an other studio
because we're gonna be doing more shows
so definitely become a member at tim
cast we'll have a special member segment
coming up later but let's read y'all
super chat super chats
all right the um youtube has this fancy
little bar that blocked me from reading
your name but i'll read your chat super
chat says hey tim you're right about the
globetrotters comparisons now let's
sneaking stack the washington generals
with some all-star players and win
i wasn't it wasn't coming for me it was
um i think someone said the other day
that the republicans are the washington
generals and the democrats of the harlem
globetrotters
like that's that's like a really great
yeah
all right tactical chiller says all are
welcome in spring water village when it
hits the fan because nobody wants to see
where this globalist plan is heading
i'll be starting a new community out at
my place 160 acre woods in ar with
spring water p.s if the irl caravan
needs a place to park in the end y'all
are welcome here well we're actually
building for damastan big news we are
we're finalizing this the the the land
purchase so that we will have
stan and it's going to be a big open
acreage fun recreational freedom plot of
land i'd like to build a factory nearby
if anyone's interested you were going to
you were going to build the free dome i
would love to build the freedom i'm
going to build the freedom
it's going to be a geodesic dome ideally
built from recovered plastic broken down
with mushrooms pestile opsis microspori
into uh sugar mixed with graphene then
we can 3d print some joints and ian will
literally live in graphene and mushrooms
yeah
i want a thousand yard range we'll have
that we do yeah um we we got some
paperwork back today we we finalized a
lot of it tomorrow it will be keys in
hand and uh oh there's a thousand yard
range
oh yeah that means the the bear will
have a home
what's the underground look like over
there dirt
wow that's a lot of potential man yeah
excavating's expensive we built a sewer
sewage system is that oh geez yeah
chicken city's got a sewer system it's
incredible that's awesome yeah we're
building a simple sewer system so when
it rains it flushes the chicken refuse
just naturally out the back i got a tour
of chicken city today it's coming along
swimmingly it's amazing i'm i can't
believe how amazing it is the custom
fencing they're building it's just you
guys got to see this go to the go go to
uh go to the cast castle on youtube if
you want to watch you know some of this
all right we got a super chat here from
i think it says horndorf
this kills me i serve the navy in the
navy to protect every american's freedom
just so the biden terror group can take
it away let's go brandon let's go
brandon
alright let's see
daniel bungie says tim quote if you say
you're opposed to the vaccine mandate
but you comply with it you are not
opposed to the vaccine mandate also tim
complies with youtube censorship uh i
seem to recall hosting alex jones
several times who's been banned i seem
to recall hosting steve bannon who's
been banned i seem to recall hosting
enrique torrio who is smeared by the
media over and over again and he's
banned from basically everything and so
there's a big difference between
say like actively participating in the
censorship and actively opposing it if
someone says i hereby oppose this now
let me go to the store to participate in
their in their vaccine mandate to uphold
it versus me being like no if we're
going to host these people we will and
we're going to create a speakeasy over
at timcast.com there's there's layers
certainly there's layers
if
these restaurants in new york city i've
explained this before but i'll explain
it again we're saying at the front of
their door i'm sorry you can't come in
unless you're vaccinated new york
mandate however if you'd like to be an
owner for ten dollars i'll give you a
share of the company and as an owner oh
you can come into the building you're an
owner right or what if they said but in
back you can do whatever you want then
i'd say hey look they're actively
opposing the vaccine mandates instead
what they're doing is they're saying
this is a bad thing this is we shouldn't
do it i'm going to go do it do you
oppose censorship i oppose
most forms of censorship exactly i'm
with you i don't oppose it i i don't
like it but i
i think that you need judicious
censorship is a good question um do we
support censorship of government secrets
in time of war say with china of course
yeah we don't want china to come and
steal all our secrets we don't know
where they're moving is going to give it
to them anyway that's true
but there's some censorship like like
you mentioned when you're curating minds
and there's gore and stuff like that
yeah i support the censorship of that
kind of stuff i i think i have my own
line though right and everybody does i'm
with that with youtube like i don't love
not being able to scream the f word
every 10 minutes because that's how i am
in real life but you don't swear
i i like to i mean especially when we're
talking about this stuff like joe biden
i want to but i you know i i
i have
i enjoy the platform and i think that i
want to
you know give the platform it's it's due
i have like over 1500 youtube videos
since 2006 i've never violated the terms
intentionally i go out of my way to make
sure that i work with the system i'm
working in
and if you don't then what's the point
i mean you could obviously
go down in a blaze of glory if you need
to make a big a point about it a lot of
people have done that i'm just not one
of those people
i think people at this stage people are
confusing active opposition with passive
opposition like they think what i'm
saying is that people actually secretly
like the vaccine manage what i'm saying
is they're not opposing it
like
if you're standing in front of a boulder
you're opposing the boulders movement if
you step out of the way you are no
longer actively opposing the boulder you
can still be mad the boulders heading
towards the townspeople yes yes exactly
people are confusing what i'm saying
they're sf to imply i'm like everybody
secretly likes it i'm like no i can tell
they're distressed you know but they're
not actively in opposition to it let's
read some more though
snosk
was at sanoski tv says truck driver
chicken in seeing diesel shortages pop
up more and more frequently the
southwest is stretched thin and truck
stops have a lot of things missing from
their shelves very unnerving never seen
anything like it
wow
dr roller gator says vocal is not
actually a bird and gator wants a refund
i bet he's not actually gator i'm just
saying i need some backstory on that
uh dr rollergator is one of the uh
one of their esteemed members of uh the
james lindsey sphere of twitter uh he's
a
a very very skilled mathematician who's
done a lot of really good work on his
sub stack he's a gator on twitter yeah
yeah he's you know he's serious when he
writes in lower case letters
tim too i've noticed
sideways 2013 says hey tim i know you've
had the situation several times will you
have a way to mirror your laptop screen
so guests can see it like a tv at the
end of the table good luck with those
studio links in fact my friends as part
of the new construction of this studio
we actually literally have that now i
don't have a laptop i have little
monitors but um i don't know if you can
do a wide shot yeah hold on let me see
and then everybody who's watching will
be able to see that we do in fact have a
big tv that everyone can look at look at
that they can see all your fancy super
chats and they can see all the chats
going by and they can see the monitor
screen this is because at the end of the
show we pop super chats everybody gets
to see it but normally it's like the
articles that we have but look at that
look at that wide shot we also have an
alpaca we do yeah do you have the alpaca
important guest it is it is set up you
can press the alpaca button i can't oh
hold on let me see which one's the
alpaca button
no that's that's me
what are you doing oh it's not the
remote the alpaca cam is actually one of
the cameras i love that wide shot on the
on the stream deck oh yeah there we go
there's a delay for me but i sure like
it yeah oh you got the alpaca yeah he's
got so we got this from alpaca farm and
his scarf is made of alpaca
hair or whatever wearing the hair of
another alpaca wool is it wool it is
wool he is in fact but he himself was
made in china give me a one in chat if
you notice that drill next to tim oh
yeah you can see a drill there's a drill
next to your left arm yeah we're still
working on the studio we're hanging up
art uh trying to figure things out we're
resin printing a custom cast irl logo
resin printing how thick is that gonna
be that's crazy it's gonna be beautiful
though
all right moose code says hey luke horse
and pony
potato potato
close enough
all right let's see
michael schwabel says the fake set for
biden is entirely so that he can read
the lines off a large monitor
i mean that makes sense yeah probably
matt mayer says tim i work in supply
chain for a company known as known for
their mac and cheese for what i see on a
daily our gears are turning but they're
starting to cease i've been telling
people to stock up we cannot keep up
with demand
but is it like great demand or is it
regular demand with no supply hmm
i don't tell
all i know is i go to the store and
there's less and less remember i was
telling you like we went to the store
and had no cream
that made me angry
yeah different store and then they
didn't have they didn't have cream with
the good like cap but they had the old
school one we have to peel it and that
spoils so quick
yeah total buffer someone just said
drama llama did you guys see that yeah
oh
lydia wants to steal veritas's thunder
with the alpaca but you know we do yeah
we can't maybe we can make them
female yeah is it retractable
i don't know
they're stuffed animals
a female
all right let's see we got here
danny beach says crap i just got my
ticket for your event didn't think do i
need one for my wife or can we both get
in on one you will need one for your
wife ladies and gentlemen it's time for
the announcements
so over at timcast.com for everybody
who's a 25 member or more we put up the
official event on october 23rd we are
doing a live hangout meet and greet at a
bar
in west virginia and we will be
revealing the full details of the
location but it's in the harpers ferry
area and ryan long and danny you guys
know danny i think his name is
pronounced polish chuck yeah downtown
paul struck
so yes so ryan long's going to be doing
stand up danny will be doing an opening
stand up routine and they'll be hanging
out with us there because they're
awesome good friends of the show and we
wanted to put on a cool event it is free
for all the members well you just if
you're a member at 25 bucks or more boom
you sign up it's right there and then
what we're going to do is tomorrow
assuming we haven't sold out which we
probably will
we're then going to open it up to all
members 10 or more
and here's the plan
day of there's going to be an open doors
for one hour for people to show up who
have rsvp'd you get a plus one and you
the wheel check membership at the door
and then you come in you get your
wristband whatever and i think we're
doing two drink tickets the event is
free for members we are paying for it um
and you know where everything is going
to be you know free you just got to show
up bring your body and nothing else
after this in the in the rare event that
we don't actually sell out and fill up
because it's going to be ryan long
performing i think even if it was just
ryan long it would sell out then we will
allow people from the public to to come
in so what will probably end up
happening is we will have there's
there's 200 available tickets which
means members and a plus one
and then once that fills up let's say we
have 100 you know 200 people in the
venue if someone says hey i can't stick
around i'm leaving and they leave then
we'll be letting people in but at that
point if you're if you haven't if you
aren't a member you got to buy a ticket
for the event which i think will be 25
bucks i'm not entirely sure exactly how
that's working out but that being said
over at timkes.com right now in the uh
members section is the link
you need to be uh 25 bucks or more
because that's basically what you got
you got the advantage that's why we
didn't announce at the beginning of the
show to give everybody
uh you know sort of a chance to go
through and get those tickets
and then uh yeah there we go so ryan
long performing is gonna be amazing i'm
super excited for this and we'll all be
there of course everybody from the crew
ian will be there
luke will be there i will be there and
then everybody else from the cass castle
you probably will be there as well
it's gonna be fun it's gonna be chicken
wings
not from our chickens and uh and ian and
i are gonna be jamming oh that'll be and
ryan long plays
he's drums a pro drummer yeah yeah so
maybe we'll see what happens and then um
maybe maybe we'll even get some other
people to play music
we'll see we'll see how it uh we'll see
how i'll have the triangle
yeah that's my instrument well it is
west virginia which is an open carry
state constitutional carry so luke can
play then
yeah it's an instrument that's one way
to put it
all right let's see josh latovsky says i
just have to say that i really like the
wider angle shots of you guys we can see
more body language making it seem like a
more in-depth experience for us viewers
and we also have the wide shot for that
purpose yeah although the challenge of
the wide shot is the ptz camera has to
manually move and reposition it takes a
second you got to get it queued up yeah
anticipate
all right let's see we got here andrew l
says can you have alex jones be part of
your team permanently he is never wrong
do you know don't you know that but
seriously can you have him back on
members at least
you know we talked about this before i
would love if alex is ever in the
neighborhood just to sit down with ian
and just the two of them he's the kind i
would party with him every week i would
love to work with alex every week but
he's in texas and we're up by harpers
ferry i feel like if uh if we just if it
was just ian and alex on one member's
only thing it would be kind of like when
you point a camera at the tv and it
creates
infinite
recursive loop
when i look into his eyes
yes
all right john smith says pilots have to
take their vaccination i'm sorry their
vacation sick pay before they get fired
otherwise they lose it the mass canceled
flights are because of this if that's
true it's to imply that all of these
people who are absent are planning on
quitting
oh definitely um
oh man wow wow see that's you're a good
business owner that's that's something
these people should be thinking about
gavin campbell says isn't december 8th
or 9th when congress goes on vacation
until the next year
is that i'm not sure
i don't know
we should look that up
let me see
brandon whitley says december 8th is
when john lennon died have to celebrate
communism brandon
let's go brandon
all right let's see what we got here
ryan
berkabil says white house says harris
didn't select actors for video it was
youtube who did according to cnn how do
we fight the fact checkers the truth and
media foundation oh yes we have a
non-profit so probably won't be active
until the beginning of next year because
we're waiting for our 501c3 status but
it's going to be a fact-checking
organization which will fact-check
fact-checkers huh i mean it's going to
be generally factoring everybody and
that means fact checkers are news
outlets same as anybody else and we're
going to fact check the reports but
we're also going to be we're going to be
doing ethics checking
that means if someone falsely frames
something we're going to give them a
strike so when snope says did luke
rodkowski you know eat ice cream on
sunday
while it's false and then says like well
it's true he did eat ice cream it wasn't
sunday and like no one said it was
that's how they play that dirty game
what they're doing now oh man i got i
got to take credit for this victory lap
everybody we had james o'keefe on the
show
james o'keefe had this big story pfizer
emails showing that they use fetal cell
fetal tissue
in the ex in the testing process for the
pfizer vaccine
and i said to james what's going to
happen
is they're going to come out and
fact-check you by saying do vex a a
viral story from veritas is you know has
people believing that there's fetal
cells in vaccines false this is fake
news it's not true
there is no fetal tissue in the vaccines
when james's story is actually in the
testing process they used fetal cells
technically correct it happened exactly
as that
exactly as as as we thought it was going
to happen easy to predict the media came
out and said people are falsely
believing there's fetal cells you know
fetal cells and vaccines due to a story
from project veritas they never said
project veritas claimed it they said due
to a
dirty dirty tricks mere merchants yeah
we're gonna we're gonna fact check them
and be like they lied i'm having a hard
time finding when congress goes on
vacation they go before the eighth i
think uh you know they get 110 days of
vacation a year it's like travel slash
no there's a there's a there's a point
here that tim just touched on that's
really really important that i want to
just kind of drag over slowly so that
people can get it
when they're checking for the facts very
often what they don't do i mean we we
joke a little bit about they're checking
to see we make sure we use the facts
that they like but there's there's
another thing that they do
and that is when you say
such and so
because of this and that you make a
point and then you bring up a fact to
back it up instead of checking the fact
whether or not the the statement that
you said is actually true
what they do is they check whether or
not they think you took the appropriate
angle on the fact right so instead of so
you might say look
we didn't always have an irs we don't
need an irs the fact check won't say
well did we always have an irs well
let's go back to 1776. no there wasn't
one true what they'll say is
uh half true yes it's true we didn't
always have an irs but here are some
reasons why we do have an irs and it's
like that's right that's not what the
check was there's the fact and then
there's the use to which the fact is put
or the thing that you think the fact
proves and rather than checking the fact
they will they will push back against
the angle or the point that you're
trying to make with the fact let's play
a game let's play a game i'll teach you
teach y'all how the fact checkers work
luke
what have you right there on the table
a big old mess
yes that that object there under your
glass can you raise it up
it's a sword pick it up show everybody
on the camera
took away my other sword all right he's
still mad about it okay claim
luke claims to have held up a sword on
tim cast irl false
experts say that a true sword requires
sharpened edges and must actually have a
a connected wooden hilt this object is a
toy and not in fact a sword luke false
or we can say true the object being held
was a simulation was it was a simulacrum
of the master sword
the point is
you can claim whatever you want and i
love the experts say
luke claimed to be holding a sword but
we consulted an expert who said that's
not a real sword so luke lied he wasn't
holding a sword
okay well i'll get an expert who says
i'm telling the truth and then i can
claim i was right so that's that's
that's not that play huh yeah it's a
replica of the sword mm-hmm it's not a
sword
it's a replica
all right let's see we got here
jeremy l says gabby kuna is a new mother
in nevada and the healthcare and the
health system is failing her please
search for her on gofundme and even if
you can't give please spread the word we
the people can help save the save her
life and help her meet her new son if we
work together
the best of luck
all right let's see
what is this
ricky l hendrick says the armed scholar
just reported that scotus will allow
biden to participate in 2a arguments
what what
well that'll be interesting huh the dude
can't
argue anything you can barely talk of
course they'll just write it down you
know
they'll write down something for him and
then he'll read it
molan lobby says regarding new york
nurse firings and replacing with
national guard one most already do that
as civilian jobs so pulling from other
hospitals
number of health workers needing nyc
alone is half of entire nyc
ng manpower uh
ng
manpower national guard manpower three
new york state doesn't accept the army
medic cert
hmm interesting oh here's an important
one it's me says let's go brandon oh
yeah that's a good one that's very
important
i've heard that do you see that kid say
it on the internet yeah
let's go brandon someone's super chat i
don't know if you came across it that uh
to look up kaiser permanente hit by
strike votes in california oregon and i
looked it up and according to this is gv
wire i think it was ap more than 24 000
nurses and other health care workers at
kaiser permanente in california oregon
have overwhelmingly authorized a strike
threatening to walk out over pay and
working conditions strained by the poor
virus that's what they say it's it's i
called it the cascade failure as work
conditions deteriorate people quit as
people quit more work conditions will
deteriorate causing more people to quit
it's a downward spiral yeah the back end
of the bell curve we went out the house
of cards that's what the yeah
it's funny alas guys it's still fun i
hope everybody is prepared and they know
how to raise chickens and don't need
medical care
we got first aid kits
ian was drinking aloe vera the other day
yeah last night i had to give some of
the guests everyone you were literally
drinking aloe yeah
don't drink the leaf it's great it's
like yogurt
what is it the herb of life or something
is what the egyptians used to call it
interesting full of water weird flower
of life something like that
all right let's see what is this what
did someone say
nextgen says you guys should jump on pop
network when it launches on the 20th of
october decentralized youtube twitch and
the eth blockchain interesting we'll
look into it
was the the
essence of immortality yeah it's the
egyptians of revered aloe drink aloe
it's cheap get it while you can throw it
like a weed apparently grow it yourself
trek god says it is not authoritarianism
when desantis says no mask mandates it
is desantis's implementing his authority
the authority that the people of florida
gave him
that's an interesting argument too i
don't completely agree with but i see
the point if people say i hereby grant
you the authority to act in this way
under these rules then them acting that
way isn't necessarily authoritarianism
if they were voted to power as an
executive to do these things however i
don't completely agree with it but i
understand the argument
there is certain things we don't expect
them to do and the masked mandate i i
don't but i don't agree with desantis
being able to mandate businesses don't
allow masks what if he came out and said
no one can wear shirts like no one can
mandate shirts no forever free foreign
why should they mandate shirts i guess
so yeah no like shirts are different i
mean i mean masks are different i don't
i don't
prefer to wear one at a store i'll wear
one if i have to when we went to a micro
center we had to wear masks and i'm like
whatever man i'll tell you this though i
have this watch and it does a blood
oxygen level check and so after about 20
minutes i decided to check and it was at
uh 95
and i was like huh so then wait another
10 minutes
and then i checked again i was at 93
percent and then i was like huh and then
i checked again and then it said 89 and
it said warning consult a doctor your
oxygen levels are getting dangerously
low and i was like that's weird and i
just lifted the mask up and took a deep
breath oh wow back to normal
i don't know i was getting yawning
breathing all that carbon dioxide yeah
yeah and so then i checked and i was
working on one
i don't know i don't know don't look at
me i'm not a doctor someone who knows my
watch said it and i believe someone had
passed out trying to run a race with the
mask on yes yeah
yeah
but but people need to realize too some
of these masks are like really thick and
some are really not thick at all yeah
you know so you could be having
something that's like super thin
people don't check which is i just think
is ridiculous it's like whatever i don't
even know the things i've asked and i've
wondered about mask mandates is
how much of the mask mandate is because
the mask is being employed properly
and correctly in an environment which it
makes a difference and how much of it is
because it makes people feel safe it
feels safe i was out in l.a and i had
the n95 mask that wasn't vented so
everything i was breathing out was not
being filtered basically if i had
coronavirus i was breathing it out
through the mask
into their face but they didn't know so
they didn't care they thought it was a
mask so they were happy i go into the
store no one said anything about it as
far as they're concerned i was messed up
even though the mask wasn't working
probably you're wearing a mask it's all
that matters whoa whoa whoa oh boy alec
norgaard says i work at my school's
dining hall ketchup mayo mustard
barbecue out for weeks
[Music]
that's it that's the apocalypse a couple
weeks ago there was a shortage of
ketchup packets up in uh the northeast
all over new hampshire people can get
small ketchup packets we just got like
40 pounds of ground mustard seed how
about ketchup
i don't i'm not that big a fan of
mustard to want to do i think we should
buy another refrigerator and maybe an
ice machine we have that's also because
i want to do cold plunges but ice
machines also would be yeah
a deep freezer and vacuum sealed farm
meat deep frozen can last up to three
years yeah yeah
dude so we got we got we need more
freezers we need a vacuum good luck
getting it yeah and it requires
electricity i think we have an ice
machine in the house we do yeah i'll
point you towards it it's about this big
okay we're getting uh we're getting
solar panels installed and big tesla
batteries
so that even in storms or whatever we'll
have four days of electricity isn't that
crazy yeah and then we'll ration it off
and you know no video games i think that
the supply line thing
is a bigger deal than maybe that we're
making it out to be it's not just a lack
of goods but i think that's kind of one
of the things that shows people what
happens when competence steps aside that
it's now
oh like there's literally things in my
grocery store that i can't get because
of decisions that are being made at a
very high level that are affecting
supply chains right
it's gonna get scary centralization we
got i'm gonna read one more kyle abrams
says tim i purchased a 25 membership and
it says i only purchased ten dollars how
do i fix that
okay um email uh members is it members
at timcast.com i imagine for member
stuff yeah but it could be something
else i don't know on the website and i
apologize for the errors guys uh
sometimes they might happen but send
those emails and uh
we'll make sure somebody gets them as
soon as possible and make sure you guys
get squared away and if you have any
issues
just we'll we'll make sure we we work
through it and figured out
and i will say uh
well we'll make sure everybody is fairly
taken care of if you emailed tonight
saying you're having issues then we're
gonna we're gonna put you in like if
you're trying to get a ticket but you
couldn't get in and you emailed us about
it
we're gonna make sure that oh yeah we'll
figure it out yeah we're not going to
leave you hanging because the whole
point is we've been trying to do events
since march and we got red taped up so
we decided you know what we can't just
not do it we need to do something and
let's just book a venue and do it and
there's a really fun venue we found and
they're like yeah cool do whatever and
we're going to do it's going to be free
if you're a member and you ask me you
show up no and and then you know i i
mentioned so i'll just do one more time
real quick for those that didn't hear
it's going to be in the harpers ferry
area
go to timcast.com if you're a 25 member
you will see it there
and uh
you can bring a plus one so if you're a
member then you bring one more person
with you we're gonna check memberships
at the door tomorrow assuming we don't
sell out it will then open up for all
ten dollar members to rsvp's so if you
wanna if you if you think you can wait
for it by all means you can but i really
do think we only have 200 tickets
and then on the day of as people are
leaving we'll allow members of the
public to come in after they purchase a
ticket or something like that we got to
figure out the ticket laws and how that
works it's not so it's not so easy just
to have an event but ryan long is going
to be performing along with his uh with
danny polish truck who is in all of his
videos you guys know you guys probably
know them from their videos we're huge
fans we're good friends and we're really
excited the first person i thought was
like we got to get ryan to come out and
do stand up for everybody that'd be so
amazing so that's what we're going to be
doing but i i i will i will now wind
things down so thank you all so much for
hanging out make sure you like the video
subscribe to the channel and go to
timcast.com also because we have a
member segment coming up at about 11 or
so p.m you can follow the show at tim
cast irl you can follow me personally
everywhere follow me on instagram at
timcast vocal did you want to shout
anything out
i'm just want to say
like subscribe follow the center for
renewing america on twitter
i'm local distance at on twitter at
local underscore distance and i talk
about post-modernism and critical theory
critical race theory all that kind of
stuff if you're looking for an in to
understand that world um hopefully i can
help right on it was weird being on the
show without headphones so i apologize
if i was more discombobulated as i
usually am sometimes but anyway the
shirt that i have on is a venn diagram
of our dystopia and it highlights brave
new world 1984 and fahrenheit 451 and if
you like the shirt and it resonates with
you you could get one exclusively on
thebestpoliticoshirts.com
and because of your purchases i'm here
so thanks for having me you guys are
really really awesome thanks for coming
vocal the man you out-hippied me by far
you look fantastic the beard is great
that's like the headband hippie level
100 hippie level 10.
he taught me everything i know
from my crystal to yours my man
i'll catch you guys later
thank you guys all very much for tuning
in i'm very excited for our event and
for having ryan long on thank you guys
for bearing with me and my ridiculous
camera switches as i'm getting used to
all this stuff you guys may follow me on
twitter at sourpatchlitz
thanks for hanging out everybody we will
see you all over at timcast.com
in the member segments and we'll see you
then
you